Boom,
we live.
Here we go.
Douglas,
Stan,
hope smoking cigarettes.
I was just a swore that,
uh,
you know what?
I'm just going to smoke outside this
time.
Last time I stuck this place up so
badly.
It wasn't bad at all.
Yellowed?
No.
Afterwards he.
Because you kept saying,
no,
I get this whole system now it's
slipping.
It's definitely dissipating.
I see the smoke sucked away,
but I remember at the end last time.
Yeah,
that didn't work as good as I thought it
was.
Gonna you really reached this place up.
It's not perfect.
You know,
you're always getting cigarettes.
Douglas,
where do you get that sugar free.
Fucking.
Yeah.
Sugar free.
I can't be good for you.
Well I am.
Now I'm going to put a splash of whiskey
in it just to hopefully kill the
aspartame taste fucking by the way I,
I,
I said occasionally say this on stage
even when there's no joke,
but when I'm just angry about it,
Stevia is an artificial sweetener and
it's a big scam where you,
there's no artificial sweeteners because
you hate getting that fucking aspartame
taste.
Right.
And then.
But then they have Stevia in it because
it's natural and it still tastes like
shit.
So you're thinking,
oh good.
It's no artificial sweeteners.
That means it's not,
oh,
it still tastes like shit,
but it's,
it's natural shit.
Have you ever had a soda?
No,
but I'm assuming it's Steve.
You nailed it.
They figured it out.
They really did.
That's good.
The,
it's not Dr.
perhaps skeptical you should be.
You've been burned before.
It's not a,
it's not coca cola,
but because it's,
it tastes lighter.
I like it a lot though.
It's good.
I don't think we have any here doing or
out.
We should get some.
But uh,
that's one of the Stevia ones.
That's good.
This,
it's different.
There's different Stevia to like,
this stuff's TV Steve.
I just generally don't drink things that
have sugar or need sugar.
I unsweetened iced tea is fantastic.
Uh,
or if it's just juice,
like with vodka I put,
I use vodka soda with just a tiny splash
of either grapefruit or so.
There's almost no sugar in it anyway.
I don't drink fucking Coca Cola.
I'll put a splash in a whiskey but tiny
where if I get fucking hammered on
Whiskey,
I probably drank,
you know,
four ounces of coke.
So it's health benefits.
Just avoid sugar.
Yeah.
It fucks up your whiskey here.
How's things in Brisbane or you're the
mayor yet?
No,
we,
we're trying to.
We're trying to find someone to run.
I would be the worst.
It's,
I wouldn't be like,
uh,
doing a cruise ship comedy where you
know,
the,
the worst about a cruise ship would be
if you sucked.
And then you have to be in the buffet
line with everyone who saw you suck in
the whole week.
You're around people who saw you suck.
That would be the mayor of bisbee where
half the town hates you for because
you're not supporting whatever stupid
fucking.
And you have to see them at Safeway.
Does your town have a split?
Is there like a conservative side of
your town and the Liberals?
That's what makes it work,
but it's not usually a,
your,
your usual dynamic of conservative and
liberal.
It's not a,
we hate queers.
It's a of the plastic bag ban.
Well,
you can't tell us we can't have plastic
bags,
but they're bad for the environment.
Will ask here because I'm used to
getting a plastic bag and yeah,
they did.
They split over just minutia and silly
shit.
That bothers you in a small town in the
town.
5,000
Jesus Christ.
That's so little.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
That's really good.
Do they leave you alone?
Are the past still bother you?
Show up at your house all the time.
Oh God.
Yeah,
but not people that live there.
Oh,
just my friends that come over.
You are.
That's weird too.
Right?
They just,
they know they'd go to busy and they can
be like,
this is the move.
Yeah,
I know.
There's no more of that.
Like an open door.
Football.
We don't even do football parties
anymore.
Gave it up.
Yeah.
Too Weird to too many people.
Just even locals.
I ended up hosting the whole time and
never watching football and yeah,
that's the problem.
Right?
And fucking clean up.
You know,
you get,
you know if 15 people over and no one's
thrown aware,
they're fucking beer cans.
Shit.
So yeah,
there's a lot of dishes or they worse,
they'd bring food,
everyone would bring food after awhile
and,
but then they'd leave the,
the pan.
So you have to scrub a fucking casserole
pan and then try to remember who brought
it so you can get it back.
That small town living.
Is that case still for sale?
Yes it is.
You still interested if everything goes
wrong.
That's where I'm going.
God,
I found another house.
It's even better because right at the
end of the runway of the municipal
airport.
So if you had your own little four
seater Cessna fucking bill burn his
helicopter.
Like it had four airplane hangar like
parking spaces.
So you could fly in park right in the
house and it was like 2,900
square feet.
They were asking like 400 for it and it
had indoors.
It had its own like giant airplane
hangar that goes right up to a bar where
you could make a stage in their shows.
That's the one.
Ah,
so it's right at the airport.
Hear other people picture.
Dude,
that's a fucking nice house.
That,
that is the runway.
Oh wait,
no,
that's the highway.
The runway is to the.
Go to the next picture.
Jamie will do this.
This fucking house is nice.
Her under this point.
His Dad,
they flip houses,
his parents.
So they came down and uh,
they went through fucking gorgeous.
This is only 400 grand or you could get
it for less.
Wow.
It's been a for 99.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
Dad was saying you could probably get it
for three slash 75.
The only problem is it's county and not
city.
So it's got the except Dick and shit.
I'm the worst homeowner ever.
I can't do anything.
And you started putting that like septic
on me.
I had a septic and one of my old houses
and uh,
the,
the pump broke and then a first the
toilet bowl started back up and then the
tub started filling up with piss and
shit.
Fun Times.
It's like all of a sudden we're in the
the bathroom downstairs in the tub
starts filling up with like what in the
fuck is going on and what it was.
This Colorado knows when I was in the
hills there was a,
had a house in,
there was a septic tank,
was slightly above the house,
see had a pump to get to the septic
tank.
So you would pump the waste into the
It's not a good idea.
Like ideally they always want the tank
to be below,
so it's like a natural flow.
So the pump broke so the tanks are
backing up into the house.
Fun Times.
That's.
Yeah,
that's the things that I wouldn't,
I,
I couldn't do it.
If I,
if I did,
if I had the money,
I would just buy that as.
All right.
This is our studio.
We don't look.
Their guests can stay here.
We'll make this into a like a place like
this.
Just a great idea.
It would be a fucking airplane.
Douglas,
can you fly?
No,
but I have learned,
but I know a pilot.
Ooh.
Better.
Better than.
He actually has a real gig now.
He was,
he would come down,
he was a fan and he would fly into
Bisbee from Tucson just to get his hours
because to get his commercial license.
And uh,
he came to a not a super bowl party.
We,
we,
the last special I taped,
he came down,
flew down with a bunch of his friends.
We taped it in business,
be my last special and uh,
so the next morning he flew back over
the house and he had put Stan and hope
under each wing and he buzzed our house.
It's very cool.
That's awesome.
Now he's a commercial,
a guy for Sky West,
that Delta partner.
And he actually picked me up at the
airport when I flew.
I flew back from Hawaii,
so he was learning how to fly and now
all of a sudden he's a professional and
that's how,
you know,
he had to build up our.
So we'd these,
you know,
stone yet before you,
you get to fly a jumbo jet
questionnaires from a lot of questions
other than,
hey,
can you fly me to la?
Like if I needed to,
do you want to talk about under
appreciated people,
the people that know how to pilot the
planes 1500 hours.
That's it.
And they make Dick for money.
I never read those stories were like in
New York where they have these like
single rooms with like eight bunk beds,
pilots living in there when they have to
lay over because you can't afford what
does this Jamie for?
And 200 and $1,500
for hours on the 2:50
for commercial sites.
I think that's non transporting people
maybe 250 hours of flight time.
That doesn't seem like a lot.
Remember what?
How bad he drived when you're 20,
how bad did you drive when you were 20?
Pretty good.
It was terrible.
I remember driving piece of Shit cars
with no worries.
Like now just to go to the store,
I'd go,
we're not going to make a on this car.
I bought A.
I used to buy a lot of shitty cars,
delivered newspapers in,
so I'd buy a car for like 300 bucks and
just beat it into the ground and get rid
of it.
I would do that when I lived on the road
and doing like tripled gigs where I
didn't have to drive 11 hours from
Arizona to southern Wyoming and hope the
car makes and you can see the ground
through the passenger side floor is
rusted out.
You can actually see pavement.
Let me drive those cars,
you know,
forever until they died and then
hitchhiked to the next town and hope you
know,
a comic there that can get you to the
city for the Gig.
Could you have ever imagined when you
were 21 or however old you were when you
first started doing the road?
They wouldn't.
He would look back on those horrible
nights with likeness stalled.
I,
I knew it then.
I knew it was nostalgic then.
I didn't,
I was shamed.
I didn't.
Uh,
I didn't think it was.
I just like,
I'm a loser.
Yeah.
I wasn't enjoying it at all.
I think there's probably a big
difference between doing it on the East
Coast and Boston and congestion rather
than the great wide open of Montana and
Idaho.
And that's a part of the shows are
probably bleaker though.
Like we had shows like you would do a
lot of road gigs,
but they were good gigs.
Like they weren't like the boom of the
late eighties.
I started in 88 and I started doing gigs
on the road hell gigs on the road and
probably like 89.
And um,
there was a lot of gigs back then that
were really good.
You would go somewhere,
there'll be 300 people.
It'd be a great crowd,
you know,
150 people in a bar there.
They love comedy night.
Like some of them were really good,
but it's just the,
the never knowing if you're going to
make enough money to pay the bills and
the stress of being poor.
I didn't have a lot of bills living on
in my car.
Well that's the way.
There's a lot of downtime at a lot of,
uh,
you know,
a questionable choices in ladies just
because he needed a place to stay for
days before El Paso.
Dangerous Gigolo days.
Shaved a little tug,
Stan hope.
Yeah.
You try the travel on the road thing.
So,
such a,
you get a view of the country that if
you really stop and think about it,
like how many different places you've
been and your,
your understanding of America,
like you've been everywhere.
You've been all the,
all the different spots.
Get a chance.
Okay.
This is how they rock it over here.
All right.
This is how they do it in Detroit.
This is how they are.
New Orleans is different.
Oh,
Connecticut's a little different.
And then you put it all together.
You get America.
But if you just like a dude who just
like parks it in Columbus,
Ohio and fucking that's that.
And all you know is CNN and tmz go,
this is what the,
this is what the country's coming lives.
These fucking lubes with fucking do
rules.
Yeah.
When you,
when you're out amongst people,
no one really gives a fuck.
No one gives a fuck.
It's barred chatter at best,
but it's.
You've never run into people that are
actually affected.
No,
you don't unless you're looking for it.
Yeah,
no.
Most of the time it's a nonissue what?
It's the most,
most pressing issue because it's.
It can shift the country one way or
another.
That's what's weird about it.
No one gives a fuck about the things
that actually affect them locally.
The thing that sets that guy off to
bitch about trump or bitch about hillary
is he forgot to move his car on street
sweeping day,
but he never goes down to petition.
City Council about,
hey,
this is fucked up.
That stop sign was obscured,
your honor,
and I,
I wouldn't have run the stop sign,
but there's a fucking branch in front of
it and you need to cut that down and I
get a ticket and I can't afford the
ticket,
and it's the economy fucking trump or
whatever.
They just bring it to the highest level.
Well,
one of the things that I've realized by
talking to people that really understand
how things work,
like economics,
like talk to Peter Schiff yesterday,
the economist,
he had them on my podcast.
Really interesting guy.
No,
no,
no.
He's a fun guy.
He like you.
You could talk to him.
He's never drunk and busy.
He would get drunk.
Yeah.
No,
he,
he's a really smart guy.
I mean,
he's a very successful guy,
but he's right there.
He's right there.
Like when you talked to them,
like I first time we did a show,
we've got drunk.
We decided to have a couple of drinks
and lighten up because he was doing this
like Fox News,
CNN thing they do where they have these
five minute panels.
We just have to rattle off statistics.
You've got to tell the people.
The problem was economics.
The problem is it like he's a wizard.
That shit.
We got to calm them
down.
My two,
we're here for a long time and so let's
get a drink.
Let's get a drink,
have a little Jack Daniels.
Then they loosened up,
but he set up a video that said,
uh,
I'm the one percent asked me,
asked me anything.
Is that what you said?
Something like that.
So went to occupy Wall Street and set up
a finger just talking to people about
economics,
like,
Nora,
this is why you think it works.
This is how it really works.
This is what I realized.
Talking to people like that,
there's no fucking way you could be on
the ball with all this stuff with
Congress and the Senate and all the
stuff that goes on behind the scenes and
lobbyists.
He would have to be fully immersed in
it.
You would have to be fully immersed in
it and then fully immersed in the stock
market to have any kind of an argument
one way or another and most people are
just having these halfassed half cocked
shitty thought out arguments about
almost everything they talk about,
including me,
including especially on this podcast
many,
many times,
but this is something that we.
It's standard.
There's too much shit to.
No,
there's too much fucking.
When it comes to politics,
like you pretend to understand politics,
like how long have been trying to
unravel this Russia thing again tuned
out completely.
I know.
I don't know and I don't care enough to
try to learn.
I get to a place.
I went through a period of,
you know,
a bag bagging,
our conspiracy theory days and then I
learned a little bit,
but anything that's.
I really don't know how government
works.
It's so hard to know.
It's just elementary school fucking,
you know,
the,
I'm just a bill on Capitol Hill.
I still don't even know what that
fucking men stopped talking.
Probably paying attention to it more
than most people.
Most people just for a minute.
Most people,
the president or anybody just represents
what they like.
Like I like a nice guy.
Oh,
I like a no bullshit guy.
Okay.
And then you just find whoever's best
fits that mold and you supply the
president who is the most popular.
Yeah.
It's fascinating though.
I.
Yeah.
I think if a trump was any
republican that wasn't a fucking
asshole,
but stood for the same principles,
there would be no outrage.
They hate his personality first,
which I'm not against you.
He's,
yeah,
he's a fucking loser.
But he's the one you created.
We were just talking about,
uh,
and I,
I mentioned it on stage here and again,
that trump makes me happy sometimes in
that he's a product of everything.
Like a,
what's that levy on ball that fucking
like basketball dad.
Oh yeah.
He's famous just because he's a fucking
asshole and he knows,
hey,
if I keep being a fucking,
the more I'm going to get noticed.
And Ann Coulter who just says,
or Tom like is,
or the news we were just talking about,
you had the new job.
People say outrageous things just to get
attention to,
um,
tenants.
You feed the trolls and then all of a
sudden you elect a troll.
So fuck you.
It's all you.
People that watch TMZ and fucking buy a
tabloid because fucking so said
something outrageous again,
but it's a natural instinct to do that.
You know,
I was telling you before the show,
Ted nugent is a nice guy.
He's like a really nice guy.
God.
Do you remember trolling his message
board from your message for you trolled
his message board and you were.
You were giving instructions on how
other people should trolls message
board.
I,
they were.
They were so like they were Magda before
MCA was mega,
like they were make America great.
I had a bit about it in my act about not
needing the draft.
He just show up at Ted nugent concert at
scoop him up in nets.
It was something along the way that
they're going to take away nascar
and I forgot that bit,
but it was even have a message board are
they know,
do they even exist because your message
board would troll and I,
I got on board with the trolling Ted
nugent's message board and I would
passive aggressively.
I would backhand insult him by going,
hey,
we got a,
we got a band together and get the news
back on the airways.
It's no fair.
All these,
uh,
you know,
rage against the machine wannabes are
getting all the airplay and when I
called the request,
true rock and roll legend like Ted
Nugent,
they laughed me off the phone and it's
no fair that all these guys are selling
out arenas and Ted nugent is stuck at
some state fair play beside it.
Tilt a whirlwind and Andy Gump,
a handful of people.
So I'm like,
I'm pro routing people to get nugent
more notice,
but at the same time he's playing 35
people at the fucking Arkansas state
fair.
It's.
Nope.
And he dancer you.
Yeah.
By the way,
I played a lot more than people.
That was the early days of people.
An understanding message boards.
I understand how they work.
That's right.
I'm glad he never brought that up.
I have,
I wouldn't have been able to defend it
and say,
yeah,
well that's Doug.
What are you going to do?
He's my friend.
Sorry Dude.
I,
uh,
I think,
I think
what we're talking about before is that
a lot of people are nice people.
They,
that this is
their act.
Their act is say outrageous things.
Get people to pay attention to them and
then that it becomes such a lousy trick
though.
I've just feel like it's so fucking
lazy.
Well,
I think it's not all that.
It's like they believed that and they
also like,
I believe Ted believes most of what he's
saying,
but I think you also says things in an
outrageous manner because that's part of
his showbiz style.
Like he's the motor city madman,
you know,
he's,
he's a,
he's a wild motherfucker is going to
tell you like it is and he believes a
lot of what he says and he makes sense
about many things.
But then he goes,
he goes,
Haywire,
what sti?
But when you're with them,
you're like,
Oh,
you're a nice guy.
Like he's a genuinely nice guy.
It as much as he says crazy shit.
He's got his,
you know,
he believes he supporting the
intelligent side of the message that you
should be able to have guns if you're a
responsible law abiding person.
And part of me is like,
yeah,
you shouldn't be.
Yeah.
But maybe you know,
maybe the problem is just like we were
talking about people running for
president,
you don't really get the nuance stance
of who a person is from these campaign
ads or debates or anything.
You just get.
You get this image is flash thing when
if you got to know almost everybody's
alright if you get to know him,
I'd say he has no reason to have his
opinion.
Like he has to be a dick just to keep
himself like Kilroy and kind of say
Rachel Jones would be like Alex Jones is
a guy who may be now he believes more
than he should have bought his own
bullshit.
But he created that.
Like that's what he.
He created his own art form and made
himself.
Ted nugent is a guy who had two shitty
songs in 1977 stranglehold is like I am
desperate to stay in the spotlight.
He's like a Kathy Griffin,
like clawing who look at me,
please notice me.
I'm still relevant.
Right?
But they go to them for opinions,
man.
I mean there's,
there's a reason why,
like anytime there's a gun control
debate,
they go to Ted nugent was going to say
the outrageous thing.
His Dad,
he's good at it,
man.
I.
It's easy to write them off like that.
The problem is like when he debates
people about gun control,
he knows to actual statistics and the
actual statistics are confusing because
you find out that this had a gun
violence deaths,
a giant chunk of them are suicide and
then there's gang violence as the other
ones and then it gets down to actual gun
violence and then the numbers,
they're,
they're weird.
They're not what you would want them to
be.
You want it to be cut and dry.
Like people are using guns and crimes of
passion and school shootings and that's
why there's guns need to take them off
the table.
But man,
a lot of what we attributed deaths are
suicides.
It's fucking dark.
How many people pull the trigger,
you know,
and a lot of gun violence is that.
And then there's.
We were talking about Chicago,
how crazy Chicago
is.
What was the number again?
1,000.
What was it?
I don't know because I had another stat
that I was waiting to pull up that day
that was crazier to me in debt and not
from like 1970,
roughly about 89.
The murders in New York City was almost
triple.
That is like 2,245
was the highest.
Oh yeah.
In the seventies.
New York was crazy.
Yeah,
it was like average or eight.
Eight,
900 I think in Chicago is what it is.
But there was one year that was 1500 in
a year,
right?
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
There's one particularly high
and it was,
it's way more than dying in Afghanistan,
way more than dying in Iraq.
You know,
it's in Chicago and this is like if for
whatever reason it's,
it's,
it,
it barely gets our attention.
You know,
guys like him are important for getting
that message out.
Even if he does it in this fucked up
way,
like how we need to look at like what
this thing is like.
We definitely have a gun problem in this
country,
but I don't know.
I don't,
I don't think either side is right about
what it is.
I think we have a fucking human problem.
The fact that humans are just running
around shooting people is the problem.
It's not the fact that we're smart
enough to figure out guns.
Well,
every time a me and Chad shank get drunk
and have one of these conversations late
into the night,
it always boils down to overpopulation.
There's too many people.
Whatever the issue is,
somehow we can always boil it down to
yeah,
but there's too many fucking people.
Well for sure
it's.
We don't value people when the numbers
are so high.
You're supposed to,
you value your close knit group of
friends.
Right?
That's the romantic thing when there's
20 million people and you can't get
anywhere like La.
You don't value people's.
Yeah.
Did a bit of bug that you love.
You love a kitten and if you get a pet
kitten and he would come home every
night.
Oh Mr Ben goes,
you make me so happy.
But if you came back to that same
bachelor apartment,
have,
you know,
300 square feet and there were 800
kittens in there,
you couldn't kill kittens quick enough.
Like,
get this,
get my golf shoes,
stomping kittens,
these fucking things.
And people are the same.
It's just like currency.
Yeah.
Well that's why what you've done as a
wise move by moving to a town of 5,000,
that's very managed.
Going to love it.
I know one my neighbors.
Yeah.
It's a very manageable to like what
you've chosen to do is.
It's smart.
I don't think big cities are manageable.
I think people just put their blinders
on and they just get weird to just get
weird.
And some people say,
well I get energy from the city.
I'm like,
I totally get that.
You go to New York City.
I totally get it.
You walk around as a bug.
So many people,
it's above it.
It's dreadful to me.
Yeah.
But I just,
I get,
I get a buzz of anger and murder.
It doesn't bother me that much,
but it does overwhelm me.
I,
I'm very claustrophobic.
And the more I age,
the more things like it just gets worse.
Well,
it's also such a direct contrast to the
way you live,
you know.
But I,
I've always,
yeah.
Hey,
I just going out to smoke a cigarette
and you can't,
like,
you're afraid you're going to burn
someone because you've sublet your
personal space and walking that close to
you.
You try to get in a door jamb just so
you don't burn the fucking pedestrian
with your cigarette.
There's no way out of it.
There's no way a thin in that out
either,
unless they make it so outrageously
expensive that literally people can't.
They are trying.
I mean that's the crazy thing is so many
people want to be there and there's so
many people there that they could just
keep jacking the rents up and jacking
the real estate payments up.
What I was saying about Ted nugent and
you were saying about,
uh,
Tom Lucas and a lot of these other
people and it's,
it's,
it's really easy to write somebody off.
You know,
it's really easy to write people off.
I'm trying to do less of that because
like I'm trying to get to a point like
when do you let someone when you like
one day,
when do you decide on recently though
was someone's like,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't like him anymore because he now
has so and so on his podcast.
Like you had someone that just some
random person was for everybody.
There's a person like that.
For some people it's a hardcore left
deal is someone I know they didn't even
listen to the fucking show,
but like Jordan Peterson was at him.
Is he like a fucking Nazi guy or
something?
Got All the writers.
Sometimes people think he is,
but he probably wasn't him.
It was probably someone more
controversial like Ben Shapiro or Steven
crowder or one of those guys would.
None of them are Nazis,
you know,
and Jordan Peterson is much more of a
centrist than anything.
He's not right.
He's,
he's more of a,
he,
they call it,
you know,
what a classic liberal,
classic liberal is,
you know,
the idea of the treating people as the
individual instead of collective into
sort of a group instead of identifying
with a group of whatever,
no matter what it is,
treat people as individuals and he's a
big proponent of personal responsibility
and treating people as individuals.
And because of that and because of some
of the things he said about they're
trying to enforce a pronouns for
transgender people,
the ones that they made up like a bunch
of them.
Uh,
there was a bill that was a human rights
violation thing,
you know,
because they have that human rights
council in Canada and it was,
he was arguing,
is this a slippery slope?
You can't,
you can't compel people to use made up
words.
Can't just decide that you're gonna make
up a bunch of gender pronouns.
And they get people to say there's like
78 of them apparently that facebook
excepts right?
There's C,
H,
I r,
C I r e.
there's just make them up like anybody
can make them up.
What you want this?
Oh yeah.
Um,
yeah.
And so because it's controversial
because people said,
Oh,
you're picking on trans people.
And he's like,
no,
I'm not.
No,
I,
I fully support your right to be a trans
person.
I just don't want to use these bloody
made up words is what he was saying.
And he felt like this is a slippery
slope to controlling people's behavior
and it starts like this and they shame
you into thinking their way and there's
a group think part of it involved.
So because of that,
he got so lumped into um,
this all right idea that,
oh,
he's the guy who hates transgender
people.
It's just like we were talking about
like people running for president.
You don't really get to see who the real
person is.
He get to see this surface.
Oh,
he's the no nonsense guy.
I'll take them.
And that's what they do with him.
I'll go,
he's the guy who hates transgender
folks.
It doesn't at all.
If you really wanted to,
like,
you would never know,
uh,
candidates true intentions.
If they were a good candidate,
if they were a crafty politician,
they would.
I would go out and say whatever the
fuck,
if you know,
if it worked for trump,
I'll do it better and I'll say shit like
that,
and then I'll just be lying.
I'm going to deport everyone holocaust
three,
whatever they want to hear,
and then you'd go and God just kidding.
And then you do the right thing.
Yeah.
I was kinda hoping trump would.
I think you could manipulate his ego to
a point where he could get them to do
your bidding just by saying,
oh,
you're getting good numbers by doing
this,
and they,
the left hates this.
So yeah,
you should legalize marijuana and he
wouldn't.
He wouldn't need logic.
You just need to have his ego fed and
he'd do all the right things.
I think that's what he's holding in his
back pocket.
The legalized marijuana.
I think as we get closer to the
election,
I think he makes marijuana federally
illegal and I think he does that.
The stoners just fucking raise their
arms in the air and they go,
fuck it.
I'm going with trump.
Do you just know how much that'll change
the world?
Just that.
And they still won't vote.
Yeah,
they still won't vote.
I know a lot of people complained it
didn't vote.
Ooh,
well Haley,
I don't.
I don't think I voted.
I know.
I know I did because I always a vote
should be able to vote online.
To be very simple.
Should be a thing.
You fill out your social security card
number.
You use a face id thing from a fucking
laptop.
You could do it on your phone
calling an 800 number,
like American idol.
That's,
you know.
I think it'd be nice if you knew for
sure and it's.
Most people have a laptop with a camera
on it or a web camera somewhere.
They're not hard.
You get a USB web camera,
they're cheap.
They're pretty cheap now and you just do
that and you've fucking vote that way.
That wouldn't be hard to do.
They been able to come up with software
that could read your face,
no fits you.
A lot of a lot of laptops.
Even at fingerprint sensors now you
could fucking vote online.
They don't want it to.
It's too they want is difficult and
confusing.
Possible.
They want to
keep it this convoluted.
Maggie,
to take time off of work.
They want you to just go like this all
the time.
Like what is this?
Who literally do it?
They don't want like smooth sailing.
Everything sorted out.
Everybody's doing well now.
They want,
like you were saying how your town works
because you've got left and right.
They want it.
They want a little just a little bit
bait to get people were inside arms at
safely,
like just just because they can.
It's.
You're in Arizona.
Yeah,
so you get that kind of redneck element,
but it's not a.
it's not a trump versus hillary and
obviously in that small town there's no
like black lives matter rallies,
but people still go out and protest for
a red,
for Ed,
for the teacher thing and see that side
on think and work in a limited amount of
people.
You know,
if you're walking around midtown
Manhattan and bumping into people
everywhere,
you got a gun right here.
That shit's not gonna work.
You know,
if you're,
if you're a guy was in Arizona,
you just worried about some no wild drug
smugglers coming across the border and
shooting up your city.
You've got to worry about that.
Don't,
you know,
like right there.
Yeah.
But they keep going.
It's the whole Carlin bit where he's
like,
people bitching about their going to
build a prison in our community and like
if they escape,
they're not going to be hanging around.
It's true going then.
It's true because you're only like seven
miles.
I'm sure I did that.
A huge injustice.
I'm sure I'm misquoting Carlin,
but something to that effect.
But yeah,
you see undocumented aliens getting
busted,
but there's no fucking drug war shit
going on.
Yeah.
They confiscate weed out of,
of,
you know,
false bottom fake gas tank at the
checkpoint.
But I know guys who have been camping on
the border or camping near the border on
the US side and had run ins with people
who were,
uh,
coming across.
They said he got.
Some of them got real sketchy because
that's basically,
they're coming across like constantly
all the time.
And you just,
if you're there,
like these guys wanna a deer hunting
trip and uh,
they just said they were just running
into people all the time.
They were looking for water.
They were looking at.
Yeah,
they'll people leave water out,
you know,
where they,
they come across a wow.
And like every other house in our
neighborhood has a humanitarian aid is
never a crime because you're not
supposed to fucking leave water out in
the desert in case someone's dying.
You're not supposed to.
They tell you not to.
I don't know exactly what the law is,
but there's placards just like every
election is vote for mayor of Joe and
vote for bill,
for city council.
There's humanitarian aid is never a
crime.
And I don't know what the law was or
what exactly,
but that's some dark shit when you tell
people don't give them water.
Have you seen that video of a border
patrol people
fucking just going out and dumping out
water that people have left in the
desert and laughing about it.
Like,
fuck you.
Oh,
did you see the border patrol agent that
ran over?
The guy that was a video that just came
out last week.
No,
I didn't smell one of the reservations.
One of the Indian reservations on one of
the border patrol roads.
A guy was filming and the car's coming
right at.
He's coming right at me and then it
fucking.
It hits him and then turns around and he
got it all on tape.
The guy that he actually hit me drove
off.
Jesus Christ.
Some fucking assholes.
Like a lot of people,
assholes gravitate.
Just like child molesters gravitate
towards,
you know,
preschool teacher and priest Fuckin
assholes gravitate towards cop and a
board anywhere they can,
you know,
oh,
look at this.
Boom.
Is that him standing up
and now laying down after the border
patrol fucking runs over him.
That is crazy.
Yeah.
I can't.
I like,
I have a hard time.
I'll get into going down wormholes,
have bad cops and fucking get here.
Border Patrol and I hit like that.
I mean that you.
Are you making a decision to shatter a
person's body?
Probably forever.
You're hitting someone that hard with a.
with a truck that guys got probably
everything's probably broken.
Yeah,
and it's on a dirt road where it's like
he did it on purpose.
There's no other excuse.
No,
he did it on purpose.
Well,
yeah.
I have too much hate in my life where I
go sometimes I just have to ignore shit
is just wake up in the morning and I get
on newser and I click on fucking cop
throws a guide through a plate glass
window kinda shaded beatings and
I,
you know,
I've said this a hundred times,
but it's worth repeating.
I don't think most people are qualified
to be cops.
I think it's a really fucking hard job
and I think the pressure of it fucks
people up.
Even if they did go into that job will,
if they gravitate towards it because
they were bullies,
which I'm sure a certain percentage do
sir for.
I think for most of them it's just a
good job and they think they can pull it
off.
I met a lot of cops are good guys,
but I think the pressure of that job and
being shot out all the time and worrying
every time you pull somebody over you to
get shot and everybody's seen those
videos of people pulling people over and
they pull out a gun and killed a cop.
There's one that's haunting man.
Guy Pulls over this Vietnam vet and he
starts.
He starts screaming for the guy to get
back in the car and the guy pulls out a
rifle and the guy just starts shooting
at him and he gets hit and screaming,
just almost like,
stop it,
and the guy just keeps shooting a cop
while all this is happening and the
guy's like screaming for his life on.
This guy's just gunning him down.
You're like,
man,
tell me these cops haven't seen this.
They're all fucked up and it's.
It becomes almost like a game and the
game is I'm trying to score.
I knew it.
It's like you're doing a.
you're playing one on one basketball.
Are you doing Jujitsu or something?
You're trying to score on somebody and
the score on them as I think you're up
to something.
No good.
Let me see.
Spread your legs.
Let me check your body.
What's going on in the car?
What do you got?
What's this?
What's that?
You're trying and if you get it,
oh,
we got it.
Score.
If you don't get it,
fuck swing and a miss,
and so you go looking for things to be
wrong and that person becomes the enemy
just like you push people on a fucking
football field or on the other team.
That's what you're doing to the people
that you're supposed to be protecting
and serving the they become the enemy.
They become the thing that you're trying
to score on and it's just stupid.
Monkey Games start playing around in
people's heads and I think almost
nobody's qualified for that.
I know of very few like big John
McCarthy,
the UFC referee.
He was a cop.
Fucking greatest guy ever want to meet
the nicest guy ever,
but he's also a big giant dude who's not
intimidated by people and he has a good
way of calming people down and relax and
people,
but he's very sensible,
like very normal and he was a cop.
His whole life is caught for many,
many years.
It's just a fucking impossible job.
Ben.
Every day you're dealing with crime.
Every day you're dealing with murder.
You dealing with people,
beating their wives,
you're dealing with kids that get hit by
cars.
You're dealing with just the most
horrible shit.
And we could boil this down to too many
people because I live in a town where I
know the cops,
same cop came to to super bowl parties
in consecutive years.
The night before when we had a big pre
party on the Saturday night and came for
noise complaints two years in a row,
the first time he walked in,
Christine Levine was on stage doing her
act and you can hear everything in my
neighborhood just speaking and when
she's on a microphone doing a bit about
my after three kids,
my pussy looks like it.
It swallowed a dog that chewed its way
out.
And I know every fucking neighbor is at
least 30 houses that can hear this over
their TV.
That's hilarious.
And the cops came.
But that cop came twice and then I'd see
them at Safeway and weed friendly and
when Bingo.
And I had our brief,
a breakup at cop came to my house.
I'm sitting in the fun house and I see a
cop walking and I'm like,
oh,
that's fucking Yannis officer Bob
friendly.
And he came in.
He goes,
Hey,
uh,
I don't know.
It's none of my business,
but I,
I heard you going through a tough time
and I just wanted to see if you're okay.
I'm like,
that is fucking cool.
And now he,
he comes over all the time and.
Wow.
Yeah,
that is.
that's the benefit of the 5,000
person town when you know everybody.
Yeah.
There's stuff that's not a homeless
guy that's broken.
We have,
but everyone knows our homeless will
work for food guy by name.
Do you think that you appreciate that
more because you travel so much because
you get to go back to that and this is
home and home is this quiet,
cool place filled with artists and
farmers and just Weirdos and shit.
But you're always like,
now you're in Dublin,
now you're in London,
now you're in San Francisco,
now you're in.
You know,
you're always moving around so much that
you get a beautiful taste of everything.
And then this is the also I,
I rarely go out.
I go to Safeway every day if I don't,
even if I don't need anything,
it's my thing.
I wake up and I go to Safeway and I find
blood.
What's,
what's good?
Discount meat.
I love a bargain and the discount meats
and other than that,
I don't go out,
don't go to bars.
I have a bar in my house,
people I know,
they come over to my house and we hang
out there.
Yeah,
no,
you've got an interesting setup,
man.
Whenever I listened to your podcast,
I'm like,
this is such a fascinating setup,
but it's the same as the comedy store,
which when I come back I love it and I
see a thousand people all in one night
that I've known you over the years,
but I don't hate anyone.
Right.
Where were you hear all the,
uh,
that fucking I hate that fucking cunt.
She thinks she's funny and she's not
funny.
And like I would be if I lived there,
if I was a regular,
like everyone else at the comedy store.
Yeah.
Then I'd have my beefs and I'd be
political.
Very few beefs there these days that
interesting.
But I'm just saying like snipey,
backtalk talk shit behind your back
thing.
I get into that again now I'm really
happy to see everyone.
I don't care if they suck.
I don't watch their acts anyway,
but that's what business is like and I
keep it that way where I don't go out.
I don't get involved in their fucking
petty squabbles and everyone's
backstabbing shit cause even when I am
there for a long time,
I don't leave the house.
I don't go out.
I don't know.
Yeah.
So I don't have to take sides.
I'm a very fucking knew saying about
avoiding conflict,
but honestly the comedy store these days
is,
is almost conflict free.
It's weird.
It's so much weirder than it's ever been
there before.
It's like this super,
super supportive community.
It's very different.
I,
I'll just say comedy in general.
What was La?
Well,
anywhere near headline in that place and
they won't give me this.
I don't have to deal with that,
but yeah,
and that's how I.
I keep busy where I go out rarely.
A lot of people don't believe I lived
there.
I just have a house there that I show up
to.
I'd say I live in,
but it would be funny.
Would it be funny if you only dressed
like this on the show and then you
immediately,
the show's over.
Oh,
I can't wait to get dressed for my golf
tee off and an hour.
And then you put on like a polo shirt
and a fat rolex.
I only have particular suits and
pajamas.
That's it.
I don't have you become ridiculous suit
guy.
Like what year did you just give in to
the ridiculous suit?
Uh,
when I got my first,
like really good.
When the one I wore a,
I forget what special it was.
I gotta like I've,
I've done this occasionally throughout
the years and I used to wear a Santa hat
for a while and then,
uh,
but yeah,
and then we dress up and just fucking
dumb shit sometimes just because I was
bored like Muslim prayer robes on stage.
Where were you getting these ridiculous.
I got this.
My neighbor Evelyn found this great old
plaid vintage 70 sport coat and I just
happened to find a pair of yellow pants
that matched it perfectly.
So then I'd start like really looking
for when I could put a whole suit
together and I'm like,
all right,
and then I realized white shoes go and
everything's white loafers.
So then I just,
every,
that's all we do when we're driving on
the road.
The only interest I have are we hit all
the thrift stores in the town and uh,
try to find good Sushi and that's it.
I'll go to a fucking museum.
So you look for wacky clothes to try on.
Yeah.
You,
you don't know.
Now I have a closet that like,
that's why I do these Ebay yard sales
every couple years and I sell all the
suits I'm tired of because my closet is
fucking buckling.
Wow.
What a weird thing to collect.
Get on the mailing list and other like
you've been doing this as long as I can
get a cool poster,
like a tour poster and you go,
Whoa,
I like that.
But as the years go on,
you just build up clutter in your
crawlspace and yeah,
you can only have so many pictures of
yourself around fans.
They'll send me artwork like yo
portrait.
They did of me and I'm like,
what?
I'm going to put up more pictures of me
in my house and he comes over and it's
just some fucking museum of you.
That's why you got to buy the house near
the landing strip.
Just turned into the Doug Stan hope
resort.
Well,
I sell the shit.
We do e Bay yard sales and yeah,
a fan would like that.
Their house.
I don't need a picture of me.
You'd like a tour poster?
That's a good move.
So yeah,
get on the mailing list that Doug
Stanhope Dot com because we're doing
another one in August.
So what do you do them personally like
to you out?
They're auctioning stuff off.
No,
it was just put it all on Ebay Stanhope
Ebay Yard Sale.
And people bid on stuff.
And a nice.
Yeah.
And it's it.
You don't want to throw this stuff away.
You can't give it to the thrift store.
No one wants it there.
So you're wearing a bunch of different
people's clothes that have lived
different,
weird lives.
You know,
think about how many,
like the kind of clothes that you're
buying,
you're buying like guys who were getting
pussy in the seventies,
you know,
like that's the kind of clothes I used
to do a bit about that and I don't know
if I ever recorded that,
but about how you,
the in the polyester under hot lights,
he,
you,
you can only imagine how bad fucking had
to smell in the seventies.
Someone was dancing all night at the
studio,
54 and oh know doing blow and then
sweating and then fucking in a bathroom
with all their pubes on and
yeah.
And no deodorant.
What was deodorant like back then?
It was terrible.
Right?
Guard Aerosol.
That's what I grew up with.
Remember when everybody thought there
was gonna be a giant hole in the ozone
layer from the hairspray.
Hairspray's going to put a hole in the
ozone layer and like apparently there's
a big hole above Australia.
Australia has it bad.
Like there's all those skin cancer and
do different.
Right.
Very rapidly in Australia.
Yeah.
I think there's a hole over there if
they ever really remember that was the,
that there it is right over Australia.
There's a God damn hole,
the image of the largest Antarctic ozone
hole ever recorded over the South Pole,
September 2006 layers of the atmosphere.
Not to scale.
The ozone layer is mainly found in the
lower portion of the stratosphere from
approximately 20 to 30 kilometers ozone
depletion.
So there's a whole.
Yeah.
And if,
if the whole world was underneath that
whole,
we'd have some fucking real problems.
You play Australia?
Yeah,
we have been.
I haven't been in awhile though.
Last time I did a Melbourne had a great
time or how do they make you say it?
Melvin Melvin.
I like Sydney.
Done Sydney there too.
They're nice.
People are fantastic.
Yeah.
That's my favorite.
And I did a Hobart Tasmania,
which is weird.
Wow.
Tasmania.
I read that.
I,
I just,
I did a couple of weeks there in April
and uh,
I've read it's called the uh,
the fatal shore and it's like this 700
page history of Australia and it's
fucking brutal.
Oh,
it's crazy.
It's absolutely brutal,
or from the time they started shipping
prisoners there for nothing,
their shackles and dying,
pestilence.
They're in,
you know,
in halls,
they sit in boats for months waiting to
be shipped to a camp.
It's just brutal after brutal.
And then a flogging until the skin fell
off his back.
And then,
uh,
and then you do an interview where
they're going,
oh,
people need comedy in these times
because there are worse than ever.
I go,
have you read your fucking history?
Trump is not the fucking worst thing
ever.
When you look at your own fucking
history.
They did some dark shit
to the aborigines too.
Oh yeah.
One of the things they did,
they took a aborigine kids away from
their parents and they tried to raise
him with a white families.
They didn't like the 19 fifties I think.
And they were telling me it when I was
there and I was,
it was one of them jaw dropper
conversations where people were talking
like,
why?
Like they stole people's babies and
raise them as white kids.
Like because they didn't think the
aborigines knew what they were doing.
So they just said,
you don't know how to raise that kid.
Me that kid.
It's Kinda like the foster system will
know because they took them.
It's not like the foster system.
The idea would be that someone would
either have to go to jail or someone who
would be murdered,
heard or something.
You don't have.
You're an unfit parent.
That's sometimes.
Right.
I guess that does happen,
right?
If someone's a drug addict or a criminal
that they'll take your kid away and put
it in foster care.
But this is just taking your kid away
because you're an aborigine.
Which if,
if their society thinks that's a bad
way,
what's wrong with a drug addict?
I know drug addicts do a lot of stuff
functionally.
Yeah.
It is.
Levels to that is levels of drug addict.
You know what's weird about the
aborigines?
They have hundreds of languages.
They,
uh,
they speak different language.
You'll,
you'll be in a,
what they call a mob.
They call themselves mom's like a tribe.
It's a mob and you'll have a mob,
but there'll be another mob that's 30
kilometers away and they speak a totally
different language.
You don't know what the fuck they're
saying and then there's another one over
there and most of it's not even written
down and there's hundreds and hundreds
of them and they're all over the.
I mean,
it's a,
it's an amazing,
strange culture.
Like the culture of the aborigines in
Australia.
My friend Adam,
Adam Green tree,
he uh,
he runs a mining company in Australia
and he works with a lot of the
aboriginal people that get some jobs and
gets to understand their culture and
talk to them.
He's told me some just insane shit about
how these people have lived and they'd
been there forever.
You know,
they've been there for a long time.
All living in these little tribes,
these little moms.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
They would have no structures.
When they first showed up over there,
the aborigines were basically packs and
they basically cut and burn or you know,
they hunt as much as they could in an
area and they didn't have houses.
They had no,
like to just move on.
Yeah.
And they were living,
you know,
like essentially like how native
Americans were maybe in the 14,
hundreds of 15 centers,
probably even more simply.
Right.
I mean,
I wonder,
it was just there.
Well that's why they wouldn't fuck with
New Zealand because the,
the Mowery,
however you pronounce that,
the Maori people would,
they were fucking bad asses and they
were somewhat fortified.
I,
I've retained so little.
I read the book and I have two days
later I have like three facts that I'd
probably have two of them wrong,
but yeah,
they weren't terrified of the fucking.
Everybody's scared of the mowery's.
Everybody's scared of just New Zealand.
People are very fierce.
Fierce.
It's just,
it's crazy to think that those two
places,
particular Australia was a prison
colony,
essentially free for England.
I mean,
that's,
that's how they treated it.
It was,
it was fucking slavery is what it was.
It was white slavery because they there.
The whole idea was to make these
prisoners build this into a country.
Meanwhile,
the crazy thing is the weather's way
better than anyone I know.
Only fucking England would use the
beautiful place as a fucking penal
colony and can't wait to get back to
fucking shop.
Share him by the sea where it's fucking
48 degrees and gloomy and shitty,
gloomy,
and everybody's just sour and dour.
Meanwhile,
you're in the Gold Coast,
Australia jumping into the water,
having a Martini on the beach.
The weather's perfect.
Yeah,
but same token.
Back then there was no fucking plumbing
and it was hard to find clean water to
drink and that's true.
Everything that'll kill you and
everything kills you,
including jellyfish.
That's what's the most fucked up.
God Damn Jelly Fish Kill you,
sally.
Fish,
salt,
water,
crocodiles,
wherever.
They just captured one in Australia that
for forever 15 feet long,
1300 cell phones.
They're always catching sharks.
Sharks all over the place.
The outside waters just surrounded with
great whites.
Oh No.
Sharks.
Saltwater kill Ya.
Spiders,
snakes,
all these different things,
but the people are cool as fuck that.
Like some of most famous too though.
Look at that.
Like I really.
Yeah,
I would say,
yeah,
you have a bunch of fucking racist and
the cheer.
Whoa,
whoa.
Look at the size of that crocodile,
the captured why in the fuck man,
it's 60 years old to how many people
have that thing eaten,
that things eating at least tie their
shoes in that belly.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
a friend of mine,
a film this show,
it's called uncharted.
And uh,
his name is Jim.
Shocking.
This is a professional hunter from
Canada.
They hired him to go to Africa to shoot
these crocodiles that were killing all
these people that lived in this village
while they were there.
Someone got snatched and taken by a
crocodile and like,
so you're,
you're seeing everyone in the village is
missing an arm or they have a chunk
taken out of their hat or a chunk taken
out of their thigh.
Like this is nuts.
Like these people are always in fear of
getting eaten everywhere they go.
They're free of getting eaten by these
enormous Nile crocodiles,
you know,
13,
14 feet long.
Just grabbing people and pulling them
under water.
I really want to go to the outback.
They have a train,
you have to train.
So one's called the Gan that goes from
Adelaide all the way up to Darwin and
they have another that goes
all the way from Perth to Sydney and I
really want to just do a train trip
because in the middle there's like a
cooper pd is a mining town where most of
the town is underground because it gets
that hot.
It's 120 degrees.
So they built the town underground.
Jesus.
Yeah.
I,
I want to go see some weird shit.
Sydney is fucking Vancouver,
right,
right.
It's not the weird shit.
And you could
drive for hours and hours and not see
nothing.
In Australia,
a lot of these guys,
they get those snorkels on their cars
and it's not for going under water.
It's just because the amount of dirt you
have to drive through.
Oh you want to have.
Yeah.
You want to have a.
You want to have a snorkel like high
above your car so that you're getting
cleaner air.
Now they all have extended gas tanks to
get these giant gas tanks put on because
they know they're going to be driving
for 15,
16 hours without seeing a gas station.
Fuck man.
That's why I thought the train.
Yeah.
No,
it's a weird place,
man.
Australia is one of the last weird
places.
There's 20 million people in the entire
country and it's the same size as the
contiguous United States of dirt.
It's all dirt and there's only 20
million people less than live in la.
Live in this one.
Huge country.
I love it.
It's like a small town but a country you
know,
like the same proportions
and it's all Darwin is the only one I
want to go to that's north and really
tropical or do you want to go to that
one?
It just sounds like a weird place to go
that it's sloppy goes.
That's where Darwin did all of his
research,
the Galapagos Islands,
some of his research compiling his
theories on evolution,
but it's apparently some crazy tropical
island that's.
They're trying so hard to keep it from
being touched and influenced by people,
but every time people go over there,
you have to clean off their shoes.
Yeah.
It's like,
uh,
the,
the don't step off the track,
but what's the fucking go back in time?
The Butterfly Effect.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
People are uh,
I mean everywhere,
but that's,
isn't that how life got spread all
across the world.
I mean,
I know we shouldn't do it on purpose and
foolishly,
but I mean a lot of how life got spread
is just things,
picking things up and carrying them in
their shit and dropping them off there
and this germs and steel.
Yeah.
I mean that's really how everything gets
spread.
We're just doing it on a larger scale
because we use planes and boats and like
Hawaii,
everything on Hawaii is something
somebody brought over everything.
Like there's some birds that used to
live there and some bugs,
you know,
and everything else is all the different
wildlife,
all the animals.
So just been brought over there.
The other worst than going to Hawaii
here in white people,
Bitch.
About the tourists,
white people that live there.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's funny.
And how tourism is destroying ecosystem.
Elon,
who the fuck are you?
That's silly.
And what would you do without the
tourists?
Yeah,
you should.
Uh,
Roseanne's going to actually fucking
make money off a macadamia nut farm.
I think she's going to be out selling
fucking nuts somewhere.
Oh,
she never had.
She never,
she,
I think I told you,
she called me again.
It goes,
I'm ready to do Rogan.
We've been going back and forth now she
says she's gonna do her own podcast.
We're going to do it.
It's just gonna take time.
You know,
I told this is what I told her.
She said she contacted me the day says
I'm ready to do it whenever you are.
I said,
you just tell me when and we'll do it.
And then we're trying to figure out I'm
in Salt Lake City.
I'm on either other sounds.
There was a little bit of that and then,
you know,
she's just trying to figure out when's
the right time.
But she said she wants to do her own
youtube channel and she's,
she's upset at everybody and,
and I felt like,
you know,
she's,
there's a lot of merit and what she's
saying,
you know,
I really do think she got fucked over.
I think,
uh,
I really do think she made a joke about
a woman that she didn't know was black
and a woman who's.
I think she's the only one eighth.
Black,
right.
Is that what you.
I saw the picture and I like,
oh,
I get it.
She talked to her on the phone
afterwards where she goes,
she was asking me for advice and she,
that I,
I really fucked up and I honestly didn't
think she was black.
And then she goes,
did you ever do ambien?
I go,
that's exactly why I stopped doing
ambien.
And I'm sure that's why she tweeted that
where I like,
just talk about this on Rogan because
Rogan spends time.
You can explain stuff.
Stop fucking tweeting.
Tweet where she goes.
I did take an ambient.
Yeah,
you drink on Ambien and your fuck.
I can tell you a million stories of
normal people like fucking,
you know,
Judy Brown,
her husband,
Steve Marmel almost had a plane grounded
because he on a flight,
he took an Ambien and had a couple of
bourbons and then just started going
fucking batshit has no recollection of
it and I've done stuff that was minor
where I just had a very lucid business
conversation with Hannigan after I'd
taken an ambient on like a light night
of drinking for me,
which six or seven beers and I went to
bed and then I get,
get up 15 minutes later and went out and
had this very lucid business
conversation that I don't remember it
all and I brought it up to him the next
day.
Something we were going to talk about.
He goes,
we talked about this last night.
No,
no.
Was,
I guess you came out?
I go,
no,
I went to bed.
Because guess what,
you came out shortly afterward.
You seem to very like completely normal.
Wow.
Kevin James,
uh,
he made dinner.
He uh,
went downstairs,
made his own dinner,
cooked it,
aided,
went back to bed,
got up in the morning and was like,
who the fuck cooked?
And then they're there like you did.
He's like,
no,
I didn't.
He goes,
like,
no.
Yeah,
you did.
Look here,
you throw this away like you cook this,
like what the fuck your brother?
You remember my ex renee,
her brother and his buddy took some
ambience,
had minor amounts of cocktails,
woke up on a lawn in a neighborhood they
didn't know where they were cheeses and
that's where it was.
That one lucid business conversation
where you go,
that could have been me driving my car
into someone's front fucking porch.
So yeah,
I,
I swore it off.
My Mom said that she took it and uh,
no booze,
just took the ambient and wound up a
drawing on a bathroom.
Carpet,
you know,
in the little bathroom rugs,
just drawing on with like lipstick and,
and nail pause doesn't have any
recollection of doing it.
Just drawing on it like a little kid
would where they pulled the nail Polish.
Just start.
It's a weird thing.
It's called a hypnotic,
that's what they called that,
that category of drugs.
The other thing with Roseanne is like
she,
well,
she's got serious mental illness and
she's on a bunch of different
medications as well.
She's got legit multiple personality
disorder.
She's talked about it and I don't think
they call it multiple personality
disorder anymore.
I think they have a new name for it,
but since the noise rebranding fucking
mental illnesses,
like,
come on man.
It's like this is what it is.
It is multiple personality disorder.
She has a bunch of different people and
you know,
if you talked to people that had been
around her and see or switch from
personality to personality,
you realize like,
oh,
and you know,
a lot of this also came from head
trauma.
She's one of several comedians that
became a different person because of
head trauma.
I think she was hit by a car as well.
Sam Kennison,
same thing.
Hit by a car and also she was in a car
accident.
I don't know if it was child molestation
or rape and disassociative identity
disorder.
That's what they're calling it now,
and she also can't fucking tell the
difference between twitter and a green
room because if every single comic was
recorded,
the dark shit that we say in green rooms
because we're comics and we saved the
worst possible thing,
especially to make each other laugh
because you go to the darkest areas and
you say all the wrong words and you say
the most racist thing to your black
comic friend and he says the fucking
worst thing to you about your fucking
ugly fucking teeth,
or you're fat or you're fucking stupid,
and if she walked into the green room
and said that about that lady,
we would be laughing.
Right.
We'd be laughing,
especially if we know who she was and
then I didn't know Ashley was saying
something racist.
You'd look at the picture,
go,
don't
get it.
I had no understanding of who that woman
was.
I never had heard of her before until
Rosana got fired and I was like,
who is this lady in?
She's saying she's the Muslim
Brotherhood,
and then Rosanne said that she thought
she was Jewish and I was like,
okay,
if you think she was black,
I thought she was Jewish and I looked at
the picture.
I go,
alright,
well yeah,
the fucking that's a,
that's not a cut and dry one.
If you read two years of Roseanne's
tweets,
that would not be the one that stood
out.
She just says fucking insane stuff.
That makes no sense all the time.
Did she say that Susan Rice,
she said she was a great big,
uh,
big ape with no a man.
Oh,
she's a man with giant swinging a balls.
This was like five years ago,
and then five years later they give her
that Sitcom and can't believe she's
acting crazy.
I completely fault ABC.
Seen a fucking cash cow that.
No,
they,
they thought they could handle her.
Hey,
we can make a lot of money by giving a
toddler a pistol.
Well,
you know what else she said she felt
like she promised not to.
What she felt.
She felt like she was being removed from
the creative process to.
Oh,
there was a bunch of things going on
even before this and that.
This was like one of the final steps,
but that they were.
She was having a hard time with the
whole process and she was definitely
having a hard time with being
overworked.
She's like,
I am all about the Illuminati and Zion
is.
Maybe we should get you out of the
writer's room.
Will not.
Wouldn't be a bad idea to do an episode
about her thinking that everything is
the Illuminati mean.
That's fucking gold comedy there.
There's so much there.
I had explained to her chem trails like,
but the thing is be different than
anybody that I've ever talked to about
these kind of wacky conspiracy theories.
When I explained to her what,
what,
how those clouds are made,
she went,
oh,
okay.
Just let it go.
Like most of them,
don't fucking let it go.
If you tell them that,
well,
you see those planes,
they're spraying overhead and go,
no,
no.
It's the heat of the engine,
the condensation and the atmosphere is
actually creating a cloud.
It's just the water vapor and it mixes
with the heat of this engine.
It makes clouds.
It's all it is.
Rosanna just goes,
okay.
Just let it go.
Like everybody else is like bullshit,
man.
There's fucking documents.
There's papers.
The CIA's admitted it.
It's one of the hardest things in the
world when you get a stupid conspiracy
theory in your head.
It's one of the hardest things the world
is to just go.
That might be bullshit.
It might be bullshit.
What's your,
uh,
what's your latest favorite conspiracy
theory?
I've dropped off the map.
The favorite one that I believe in.
Yeah.
Or Man,
I don't have a good one that I believe
in.
Are there new ones that people are
always.
There's always new ones.
Everything.
Everything's a goddamn conspiracy.
This is like constantly everything that
everybody does.
What's a good one?
Jamie?
What's a good recent conspiracy theory?
The Russia stuff,
but I can't.
I can't make heads or tails this Russia
shit.
I.
Every time I read the Muir documents on
the reading what's been reported and
who's getting indicted and I'm like,
this is.
Yeah,
I,
I.
This is too much zoomed out early.
He just asked for a 100 blank
indictments yesterday.
Meal or did.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
100.
What?
Did they arrest trump?
Are they allowed to arrest him?
That's part of what the whole thing with
the judge is going on right now.
The Dude Court judge will.
Somebody was explaining the relationship
that the judge has.
The judge who stepped down has to.
Trump is his son is trump's banker from
Deutsche Bank.
Okay.
Geez.
Ooh,
that's too much space.
Yeah.
Occasionally I'll look in.
Okay.
Have,
you know trump and Kim Jong Il and
Dennis Rodman or in together into visa.
Poor.
This is the new.
Oh,
the newest one is the new fake Melania
trump.
They think the new body double that.
Melania is not going on these trips
anymore.
I know that one of you called Alex Jones
who he would,
uh,
he'd yell at us about it.
Is it true?
What does it say?
Two hours ago.
This,
this article up.
Okay.
Erie.
New Pictures.
Melania trump.
Reignite conspiracy.
Conspiracy theory.
She's using a body double.
Okay.
What are the pictures?
It's supposed to be her and 2017.
Okay.
Uh,
what website is this by the way?
I don't know.
You're not even going to check.
Click the first.
I just went to the first one that was
just posted that.
Well,
what are the pictures down low.
That's when that it's supposed to look
weird.
I think if you scroll lower.
Yeah.
I think we have an answer to why
millenium is missing so much lately.
Look closely.
Yeah.
It doesn't look like her,
but that's only in this.
I mean that does not look like Arab.
Only in this presidency.
Would this be something that we would
think about only this is the like we're
like,
man,
that ain't even his wife.
These you've got your body double.
Like what are they going to do with
Melania leaves him.
He's going to get a double because you
going to get a body double is just going
to give her money.
It could just go hooked up with this
chick on tinder.
Like what's going to happen?
Like at what point are people going to
stop being completely be fuddled that he
said something and
stormy Daniels got arrested yesterday.
That's,
that's,
that's some bullshit.
Sue's touching an undercover cop.
Was it she was touching on the cover
crop or she allow the undercover cop to
touch her?
I believe that,
but what I read from her attorney last
night on twitter is that she'd,
this is the same show or whatever
performance she's been doing all over
the country.
It's like,
it's what she does,
that she was going to do it.
So it was almost a setup or something.
Yeah.
She wasn't blowing a guy in a fucking,
you know,
the champagne room or something.
When you read the law it said the law
was that you can't touch someone in an
adult establishment unless it's a family
member.
That's the fucking law.
Whoa.
So you walked over to Jamie and rubbed
his back.
You'd go to jail.
Unless we're related.
We haven't done a 23 employee who
regularly appears nude or semi nude in a
sexually oriented business is prohibited
from touching patrons except for family
members.
Huh?
So,
uh,
that's
Smith.
Oh,
there it goes.
The charges were dismissed according to
court documents,
so it almost makes it more news that she
was arrested.
I wonder if it was like a rogue cop
who's like a fucking trump fan was like,
fuck dude.
Booch.
Absolutely do it for Donald.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it can.
Absolutely.
That's not a well thought.
Well oiled planned by the White House.
That's a plan by one fucking yahoo with
uh,
with three different mega hats at home,
you know,
on the foot.
Fucking thorn in his shoe was bitch.
She thinks she's going to take down.
Potus is my favorite when they call him
Potus,
you know,
like they,
like with potus did this.
He does.
It's trump.
We've got to stop.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
that's one syllable.
Not only that,
it's like this is what got us here in
the first place.
Daniel's removed.
What?
Okay.
Then probation affidavit obtained by
CNN,
uh,
detectives who were at the sirens.
Gentleman's club said they observed
Daniel's.
Remove her top and force patrons.
Face intern.
Chest force.
Yeah.
While she's a monster.
She wasn't here for this.
Yeah.
It's not like she did that to a trained
killer with a gun to a cop.
It's not like even a regular guy.
It's a guy who makes his living stopping
crime and she stopped being fun Vice
Cup,
but he can't even stop to plunge like
he.
She forced him in there.
There was nothing he could do about it.
It was basically rape.
Nothing he could do.
He couldn't go,
hey,
stop another.
Me Too.
When officers witnessed those
activities,
three detective approach to stage
Daniel's allegedly made her way towards
the two.
Detectives leaned over and grabbed their
faces.
She shoved each of their faces,
her breasts court
documents said,
come on.
They locked her up because the officer's
face with her breast,
they,
they.
I can't believe that she found a third
officer,
his buttocks and breasts according to
the document and then force the officers
had between her breasts and smack the
officer's face with her breast.
Imagine arresting somebody for that.
You fucking lazy.
Civil Servant Leach.
You Leach bleach.
There's money that could have gone to
schools as money could have gone to fix
streets.
Money could have gone to all sorts of
good things in the community,
but you leached it.
You fucking snail just creeped over.
Get that lady to touch you and arrested
her.
Well,
I did get $6,000
bail.
Yeah,
but she's.
The charges have already dismissed.
Doesn't she get that money back?
I think so,
yeah.
It's a particular bus.
Fucking ridiculous.
That's the thing that you're saying
there,
but this is cops.
Some of them are awesome.
Some of them are awesome and just get a
certain small percentage of them that
ruined it for everybody.
It doesn't even have to be one percent,
but one percent of cops out there
shooting kids.
I mean it's less than that because it's
less than.
It's not even every day,
right?
A a cop doing something fucked up.
It's usually like once a week I think
I'm fucking millions of interactions
these cops have with people.
I mean every day something's going wrong
all over the country.
Someone's pulling someone over that as a
gun,
someone's pulling something off,
someone over that as an expired license
or stolen property or they're just
constantly dealing with people.
It's amazing.
I think she was little.
They do.
There's an argument in,
hey,
the cops should live in the community.
He's policing.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
That most certainly is.
Otherwise you're an outsider.
Right?
I mean that was a,
how they used to be like the cops.
If you were in,
you know,
in New Jersey in the 19 seventies,
the cop that was patrolling your
neighborhood lived in the neighborhood,
it's probably all knew him by name.
Yeah,
totally.
I like cop friend in Bisbee told me a
story about where he had to do a welfare
check and a house and he's forced entry
and he's yelling,
police,
we're just here to do a welfare check.
Hello.
Some older guy that could have been
fucking dead.
And he's expecting to,
uh,
to find a corpse when no one's
answering.
And he gets up the staircase and he gets
halfway around.
And this guy with half dementia holding
a fucking a of 45 on him and he has to
make that split second decision to draw
his gun and shoot.
And he just ducked the other way.
Hey,
we're just here to make sure you're
okay.
And he was like that close to taking a
fucking bullet in the head,
just trying to make sure a,
a neighbor isn't dead and you okay,
I understand where it's getting some
fucking Harry predicaments where if he
shot this fucking old guy,
oh,
could you imagine shooting old guy in
his house because he thinks he's
protecting his house for burglars and
you're just there to check to see if
he's all right and you wind up shooting
him in the head and you know,
this just the amount of days in a year
and the amount of interaction they're
gonna have with violence.
It's just too much for most people's
brains.
Almost everybody's brain.
It's almost like being on the front
lines for 20 years,
especially if you're in Detroit or South
side of Chicago or somewhere were
terrible neighborhood with a dealing
with crime all the time.
Camden,
something like that
was,
uh,
the,
the thin blue line where our officers
protect their own fucking bad apples.
Yeah.
You only need to see,
you know,
one fucking wormhole run of youtube,
bad cop videos.
Well,
there's people that are protecting those
cops.
So yeah.
You get a fucking give up your weak
links.
What is the documentary,
Jamie?
The seven five.
Is that what it is?
Is that what it's called?
For sure.
Seventy fifth precinct.
Have you ever seen that?
Michael Dowd is a documentary about a
crooked cops in New York.
Shit.
Is it good?
Yeah.
That was really holy Shit.
Is it good?
And you realize how crazy it got a.
They would just run a thing.
Selling drugs and planning to do hits on
people like,
Whoa,
isn't really fuck.
That's a good documentary.
Nick depalo turned me onto that.
That's a good God damn documentary.
I thought they only did stand up comedy
on Netflix.
Now they have a lot of God damn
documentaries.
Have you seen the wild wild,
the know the wild wild country?
Have you seen?
No,
I haven't seen that.
I just got back on Netflix.
I've been out of the country for four
months basically.
But uh,
I just watched a evil genius about the.
How's the pizza bomber?
Four parter.
Uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's really good.
I,
it didn't need to be four parts.
Every documentary you watched could have
been a third shorter.
Yeah.
Uh,
but yeah,
that's what the guy with the.
The neck bomb.
Yeah.
And His fucking head blows off.
They send them into a bank and they
still don't really know if he was
involved.
He wasn't involved,
but is a really good documentary.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's just the wild,
wild west.
Wild country is
about a sex cult that took over a town
in Oregon.
Oh yeah.
Nineteen 80.
I was looking for that.
That's the one I was looking for,
but I know it was the Bhagwan shree rush
and I'm like,
I don't like to search Bhagwan how do I.
I wouldn't even know how to spell that.
I wouldn't even know how to spell that
enough for Google to correct it.
I know about this whole thing before the
documentary series came out.
I knew about it.
I never heard of it,
but
not in depth.
And I've heard it's a fucking brilliant
documentary,
but I didn't know the name it.
Um,
it's,
I'm amazed I could have,
I just said Bhagwan Shree Rajneesh.
That is pretty amazing.
I'd just call them Osho.
It's with,
they call them later.
Right.
But it's A.
I didn't know it happened.
I had never.
I had never heard that this was a thing
that there was a whole town that gotten
taken over by this wacky call.
I never heard a peep about it.
So when this documentary series came
out,
this is all,
what,
when was this like totally to you?
Yeah,
that's how I remember the name,
but I didn't know the details.
I didn't know that,
you know,
the criminal element of it.
I just was like the,
the Reverend something moon?
Yes.
Yeah,
the moonies.
Yeah.
I just remembered existed.
I don't know anything about.
Wasn't that Steve Hanson guy?
The guy that's the.
A cult expert.
Isn't that what he was in?
Wasn't he in the moonies when he wound
up leaving?
Was that what it was?
They found him when he was in college
and recruited them.
There's a guy who was a,
uh,
an anti cult educator and uh,
he was in one.
He got roped into one when he was in
college.
Well,
he's a,
he's Jewish Unification Unification
Church,
which is that Mooney's says,
Huh?
What does it say?
It says Annie founded ECZEMA ink.
So that might be.
Yeah,
I think it was the moonies.
I think the unification church is sung
on wounds church.
See if that's true.
Um,
is it?
Yeah.
So he was,
he was roped up with them when he was in
college and he got rescued.
Who rescued him?
Someone's family member or something
like that.
I forget the whole story,
but I wonder if Alex Jones ever does
that.
Hey,
look that up.
Is that true?
No,
it's not.
I don't think he does.
You can't believe that fact,
those,
um,
I just can't believe I never heard about
that whole story until it went down or
until the documentary series went down.
I never heard that story.
It's almost like a,
I was living in an alternative universe,
like how do I slip this?
They took over a whole town.
How did.
And this is when I was a grown adult,
this was in the late eighties,
like,
how the fuck did I not know about this?
Well,
I fucking scientology did with
clearwater basically.
Did they?
Well,
I don't know if they took over the town,
but they close close,
but this,
these people took over these Mormons in
Salt Lake.
How did I not hear about.
When you see it,
you realize the scope of it.
When you see the old home movies,
you realize like,
oh,
like they,
they,
they made a whole town.
They took this whole.
They had this ranch and they said they
couldn't have the ranch.
They couldn't turn it into this town.
They couldn't develop on it the way they
wanted to because they were.
They were recognizing that these were
becoming like a,
a giant caught that was next door and
all these people are moving in and so
they said,
Oh really?
Okay.
We'll just,
we'll just stop buying the houses in
this town and knocking on everybody's
door and go,
how much do you sell your house for this
tiny little house or a tiny little town?
So just like a busy type place.
They start buying everybody's house and
then they started shipping in homeless
people.
They shipped and homeless people and
took care of them.
So the homeless people would vote dude.
The whole thing is they let anybody
join,
just get on a bus,
you can join,
and they drove him out there to Utah and
then they created like thousands and
thousands of people,
Oregon,
thousands of thousands of people and
they took these people and that they
made them a part of the community and
they used them for voting and they took
over this town.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
When you're watching it,
you're just like,
how is this not mainstream news that
this.
How is this not like Jonestown massacre?
So it seems almost more impressive.
Less people died,
but I don't know the,
the,
the dark element of that.
That's what I don't remember.
I know that they did some fucked up.
I don't want to give it away.
You got to watch it.
Don't,
don't give it away.
It's fucking amazing.
And what's amazing is they got so much
footage.
You could see what these guys were like,
like carrying machine guns.
They took over the police force,
they call it the piece for us,
but they're all got fucking
semiautomatic rifles and shit.
And there was more.
Jeff's in Colorado,
Utah,
Arizona,
Utah border.
Yeah.
He's a Mormon,
right?
He's the.
He was radical political now,
but he's still running things from
prison and the family still somewhat a.
What did they get him on to get him on
polygamy child.
He had a fucking,
like a 16 year old wife.
One of his wives.
It was child rape.
There's a good documentary about that.
A false prophet.
Something Prophet,
a Jew,
you know that.
That's the whole reason why a Mitt
Romney's families from Mexico.
Did you know that?
Know Mitt Romney's family moved to
Mexico back when they made polygamy
illegal in Utah.
Oh yeah.
Here,
what is this?
An exclusive look inside the compound.
Warren's Jeff shared with 79 sister
wives.
He was Hashtag Bolin 79 hits homeboy at
79 wives and they're all ugly as fuck.
I got a role.
Hot bitches.
No,
I think it was a hot one that got out.
She's in the documentary?
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the Mitt Romney clan.
They moved to Mexico when they started
putting all these restrictions on them
and the United States,
like,
no polygamy.
No,
the parents.
Super,
Super Mormons.
They were.
They'd polygamist yet?
Well,
they were in the ones that left and went
to Mexico.
They were whether they were still
polygamous when they were his parents,
I don't know,
but when they initially established that
sect,
they moved to Mexico specifically to
avoid the laws
of the United States and there are
several of them.
There's more than one family there and
they have to fight off the cartel.
There was a vice piece on it.
Fucking crazy,
man.
These people,
they are armed to the tits,
wandering around their compound.
They got fucking barbwire fences
everywhere and they're worried about the
cartel coming in and they get kidnapped
and they have to pay ransom and
everybody knows they have money.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
That's Mitt Romney's parents.
Polygamists versus the cartel.
Yeah.
I forget the name of the vice piece.
Just meet Mitt Romney's Mexican.
Mormon family drug cartels.
Diverse Mormons.
It's a seven part series.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's what it's called.
Yeah,
there it is.
It's fucking wild.
So they go over to Mexico and hang out
with these people.
You go to Mexico and they have this
enormous Mormon community in Mexico
fortified.
Well,
someone was telling me about,
uh,
you have some viral piece snapping on
immigration and anyone who will take
away their baby
parents.
Yeah.
It was just a,
me and Duncan talking on a podcast about
how crazy it is.
The people like
good should have broke the law.
Something about trying to get rid of the
fucking end it if you,
if you believe that's okay,
don't follow me.
Don't listen to me.
What I said.
You sure you're not on the team like the
team?
Yeah.
Humans.
Like if we're going to act as a country,
you know,
the thought is we're going to act as a
country.
We've got all think we're going to help
each other.
We're to support each other.
We're going to look for the values of
community from these team members that
are on this team together.
But if someone's like,
shouldn't have broke law.
Oh,
she's losing her kid shouldn't have
broke the law.
Like how the fuck you going to let
someone like that on the team about
this.
Yeah.
Like the way it was described to me last
night was that you were telling a lot of
your fan base to fuck off and I don't
know if you're getting.
What I'm getting is a lot of fucking
mag,
a fucking Nazi type shitheads like are
you.
Yeah,
and I.
I said it on stage last night that the
same way people can be offended at a
buzzword without hearing the whole bit
because you said contar retard or
something that they just completely
tuned out and walk out without hearing
the context of the whole piece of
material the same way people can become
attracted to you because you said,
you know,
faggot Jew without hearing the context
of the bit and like I'm having to force
people.
Like I don't want you as a fan.
I have enough fans.
I've lived my little niche base and you
can go away and like the Libertarians,
I have to distance myself from them
because that was always a split
of know civil libertarians and legalize
drugs.
That versus snake handling,
homeschooling,
Christian types that don't want the
government involved in them raising
freak kids.
But now it's like,
it seems like all the good parts are now
just anti-trump,
like we have to vote Democrat and the
bad parts of the libertarians are the
whole now where I'm,
I'm not a fucking lit.
I Lean Libertarian,
not the party,
but the ethic.
I leaned that way,
but I'm not calling myself a libertarian
anymore because there's a bunch of
fucking Nazis.
Not all of them,
but I'm saying a lot of people have.
It's become the good parts have left.
Well,
I think there's just a problem with
groups.
Whenever you have groups you're going to
have the fringe and when you have the
fringe was the French stupid or the
fringe?
Radical.
Right?
Or the fringe radical left.
They sort of define the group and they
it.
And if you have a group that anybody can
join,
like do you have libertarian ideas?
Yes,
I do.
I support a lot of libertarian
philosophy.
Good.
Become a libertarian.
You'll be with us,
you know.
But there's,
you know Dave Smith at all from
legionnaires.
Mayor.
Oh,
different guy.
Dave Smith from New York comic from New
York.
So legitimate libertarian had they.
I think I just did a podcast with him.
I'm sure he.
Did you do the skanks in a legion of
skanks?
Yeah,
but I think it was without big J.
I don't know.
Okay.
It was as I was promoting my book,
so I was doing like 18 things in a day
and drinking the whole time.
I think I'm a little loose on the
details.
Yeah,
I know those kinds of podcasts.
I think there's a,
it's,
that's a legitimate,
this podcast where I go,
you know what,
I'm not going to fucking smoke in his
studio this time and I'm not going to
drink.
It's worked here.
I am,
but.
But the uh,
the smoke things working,
it's not bad at all in here.
Right.
It's pretty good.
It's way better than it would be if
there was no,
no fan thing.
What the fuck were we just talking
about?
David Smith?
Libertarians.
Yeah.
But the problem is just being in groups,
man,
you know,
like identifying as a right wing,
identifying as a left way.
I didn't.
So,
so many people that identify.
You just grab those ideas.
Usually one issue.
Immigration.
Yeah.
I'm against it,
so I'm right wing the rest of your day,
your abortion.
If your pro your pro choice,
you have to be left wing.
Like there's the right wing people that
go pro choice,
they get attacked.
That's one of those weird things where I
think racism will stop them.
Overturning Roe vs Dot Wade.
Racism will.
Yeah,
there you go
there against abortions,
but not for all these Mexicans having
all these kids.
That might be the only way.
Right.
I was always on Frankie Boyle show and I
was saying that,
uh,
that's the only way that,
of trump would overturn a gun control
put in gun control laws is because
school shootings are the only time he's
not on CNN when that it takes like 30
people to die on a school yard before
CNN stops talking about them for a
minute,
steals his air time.
We're going to abandon going to ban
these assault rifles because I'm not
getting air tight.
They're talking about these dead kids
get me back on TV.
Even if they had a story about a school
shooting,
they would have Russia scrolling across
the bottom.
The scroll across the bottom is like the
ultimate insult to your attention span.
It's like,
I know you can't pay attention to just
what's on the screen.
Stupid.
So I want to give you some extra data.
How about the stock market?
I'll leave it for you up here.
You know how much money you're losing
constantly and then fall this ticker
tape of sadness and despair below you in
the stocks?
No,
I mean I have a business manager and
some of it's invested in some different
things,
but I don't pay attention to it.
I,
I get,
I get some stocks were of a friend of
mine talked me into and I,
I get it like every couple months.
My stockbroker caused dog.
It's stay via for I want to make some
moves and the last time I actually wrote
down he'll just start spewing this
jargon where I put them on speaker phone
in the van when we're on the road so
everyone can hear his is just.
I go,
I do you fist pump.
Are you on top of a desk?
Like wolf of Wall Street,
fist pumping as you're selling me this
bullshit because I have no idea what
you're talking about.
But I,
I,
it's fun.
Like I,
I get stocks like I think like initially
it was like in everything terrible like
Philip Morris and craft and big Jose.
Can I add?
Can the craft.
I love kraft macaroni and cheese.
Could that be my stock?
I go,
yeah,
you could look it up for the USA Today
to see if it went up or down.
Yeah,
the tobacco money.
I mean you smoke cigarettes,
you should be allowed to invest in
tobacco.
But yeah,
they were into a lot of other shit too.
Sure.
I don't.
I don't know if I own that anymore.
I was at Pfizer stock and it's a good
one to viagara kraft macaroni and cheese
and fucking cigarettes.
Sure.
Just the stock market right?
Self,
like just trying to pay attention to
that too.
On top of all the other shit you're
supposed to be paying attention to.
It's supposed to be paying attention to
stocks and bonds and up and down and
yeah.
I,
I stopped paying attention because I'd
get calls where he's moving
it into this and I don't know,
and then I have to fucking look up fits
up or down in a few shit.
You're working on your act and if you're
working on a year,
if you can do your podcast or you're
working on your act or getting ready to
go on the road,
you're going over your material.
How much fucking time do you have to pay
attention to the stock market and really
know what you're investing in?
Really doing the research on the
company.
I don't of course know it's crazy.
I get reports and I see if this number
is higher than this number.
This has no fucking time.
Douglas,
there's no time for you.
There's no time because you do a lot of
shit and you're very ambitious to two.
A two and almost a pathological extent
where I have all the fucking time in the
world and I'm always riddled with
anxiety.
Like I can't.
I do nothing but I can enjoy it.
It's not like I'm relaxed,
like there's something I should be
dealing all the time too.
Where I'm,
I'm paralyzed in bed because I don't
know what it is they should be doing.
I know there's something,
but I think if you do more things,
that feeling goes away.
I could do like if you do things that
you're,
you're really tuned into things that are
like require your attention than the
anxiety of not doing things goes away.
Then it just becomes a matter of doing
things.
Yeah.
I want to enjoy doing nothing.
Like I told you after this week,
by the time this airs it'll be Monday
and I will be retired and I do this as
often as I can.
Every few years I quit comedy in my mind
where I just.
I have nothing on the books.
I have no dates booked.
Now I don't have an act.
I have used this act in every fucking
English speaking place that I've done.
You know,
all of us.
And now I've done everything
international.
I've done fucking ex pats in Vietnam
have heard this fucking act and I have
to start from scratch.
And that's you.
That's.
We talked about this.
You're starting a new hour ruthless as
it was process.
So I want to have that moment in
mentally where I go,
I can do anything in the world right
now.
I can just,
I can fuck off.
I could write another book or I could,
but I,
I have no commitment just having that
and I still won't enjoy it because
they'll just sit there.
Anxiety fueled to go.
I should do something.
Well,
we're always looking for a break.
We're always looking for that moment of
relaxation.
A moment of I just,
ah,
but sometimes your brain is a wire.
That means having nothing.
Like I don't want to have a gig booked a
fucking year from now.
So when you do that,
do you feel good?
You've done it a few times.
I,
I can make it a few months.
It's,
I,
I'm not.
I'm not a person who needs to be on
stage.
I can not do that,
but I have to do.
No.
I drink too much because I have no
reason not to.
Hey sure.
Mimosas at 11.
Well that's not going to stop.
Well,
you've written two books now.
Yeah.
Do you write books during those periods
or do you just during normal times I
wrote those two books because I agreed
to and cash the check first.
Then you have to write the book.
I'm not a guy who does things on Spec.
Hey,
this is a great idea for a TV show.
Let me write it up and shop it around.
No,
yeah,
I get to check first or I signed the
contract first or I agree to do the gig
first and then go,
ah,
fuck.
I'm going to have to have a new hour
before I do that tour start writing.
But uh,
again,
I,
I have minimal needs.
My Shit's paid for and I don't have
kids.
I'm not in a,
not in a pickle.
Like,
you know,
you've done it really well as far as how
to manage your time,
manage your time and manage your,
uh,
your freedom.
You got it in a good place.
He'd been very smart with money too.
You didn't do anything stupid and get
drawn out,
you know?
Yeah.
Live low.
Just slip smart.
Buy Thrift store clothes.
Live in a small town.
It's a good way to do it,
man.
I mean the,
the,
I think what I seek that I don't have
right now is the balance between,
uh,
the large numbers of people,
the pressure and then more downtime.
Like I feel like I don't have enough
downtime and then I just think as a,
just as a person is paying attention to
way my brain works,
I'm like,
this is not that healthy.
Like I'm doing too many things.
Like I should have less things to do.
It was so much fun to watch you at that.
Uh,
what's the show you did the stand up off
the top of your head.
Stand up on the spot.
Yeah.
And he was like,
yeah,
it's really fun.
Come on up.
And uh,
yeah,
you just uh,
and I saw you do that the last time I
was in town and it was fucking
brilliant.
I go,
that was just,
you were just riffing that that's not
because you were talking about.
Yeah,
I only have like 10 minutes.
Like I'm trying to write a new act that
I only have like 10 minutes of good
material and then I watched you do 10
minutes off the fucking top of your
head.
That was brilliant,
but it was really funny to see you in
that backbar.
God.
Yeah,
but I gotta be fucked up to do it.
Drinks.
You kind of have to be.
I've done that show sober.
It's a.
You want to be super high and at least
two drinks in.
That's what you want.
You want to be lit.
You don't want to be too late because
then they'll go down a dumb path that
doesn't really work.
Like you want to be good enough that
you're.
You're lubed.
Yeah.
You're lubed,
but you're still.
You're still moving good.
You still go,
oh,
okay.
Here's what's wrong with that.
Whom?
And then you go right into it.
Let's just start talking and wait for
the funny words to come
out.
Don't pause.
Yeah,
don't think about what's just exercise.
Those weird.
A improvisational muscles,
you know,
but it doesn't always work.
My last one was not good.
I did one like a month and a half ago or
two months ago.
When was the last one?
It wasn't good.
I got nothing out of it.
Sometimes it just get nothing.
Do you record always?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
That you.
You get these gems out of that show
where you like,
oh Jesus,
this is my next five minutes.
I've got it.
It's right there.
I know where this goes.
This is going to go to that and that'll
go to this and I can tie it all
together.
Boom.
And you'll,
I record.
But it to get to that Jen,
if I just did a,
you know,
an hour and 40 minutes,
hammered and I.
There was three things usually.
Bingo used to be on the road with me and
she would sit in the back with a yellow
legal pad and she knows my act,
so if I come up with something new,
she'll write that down.
And the next day in the van Gogh,
Oh,
you said this,
she said this.
I'm like,
Oh fuck,
that's great.
And you don't have to listen to yourself
and cringe for fucking,
dude.
Here's a thing.
Listening to yourself and cringing is
good for the.
I know it's the best thing.
It's good for this thing you can do and
but at the same time I hate myself so
much that it's disheartening.
Is that what I sound like?
I shouldn't do this.
I fucking suck.
A familiarity breeds contempt and when
it's yourself too.
If you're going to be worth a fuck,
you're going to be hypercritical of
yourself.
It's just a fact.
So you're watching or listening to
yourself and just like,
oh,
shut the fuck up.
I heckled myself alone,
listening to myself and dropbox and I'm
like,
just get to the fucking point.
Yelling at myself.
What do you record with you?
Record with your phone?
Daily records using an MP,
three players to little unit that we
were on the road and we just bring two
mikes to podcast on that little thing.
Zoom?
Yeah,
zoom.
that'll be better at I,
I do it on my phone just so I have them
there all the time and then I listened
to him on my way home.
But I have a ritual I listened to set on
the way home unless I don't have to.
Like if I do a set and I'm like that was
just textbook.
There was this by the book on autopilot.
That one?
Yeah,
but if there was some new bit or one of
those stand up on the spot shows I
listened to it all the way home and then
once I get home then I'll break out the
laptop.
Then I'll start writing just like,
all right,
I got the spark going,
let's see what the fuck comes out of
this.
And I just feel like a lot of it is just
throwing shit against the wall until
something sticks.
And if you don't,
if you're not out there throwing shit,
it's not going to stick.
But bold while you're doing it,
you can't believe them throwing all this
shit but then swap a lot of times when
when you get so bored with a bit,
you know,
like this,
like any special.
I probably have three.
All right,
this I have to do these three bits,
but then you're tired of them and then I
just start
fucking around with it just to make it
interesting for me.
And that's a lot of the times where you
find,
oh this,
this works.
Sometimes it works better,
right?
Yeah.
Sometimes you'll find,
I mean comedy is one of those weird
things that you have to do in front of
people.
You can,
you can write and you'll.
You can get seeds,
but you got to plant those seeds in the
dirt of the crowd.
This is the only way.
It's the only way I can see it.
Occasionally I'll come up with a bit and
it's done when I come up with it.
Like I know I know the premise,
I have a setup,
I got the punchline,
boom,
and it's done.
And he could bring it to the stage and
never changes.
But that's like one out of 100 bits
maybe,
right?
Yeah.
This was my first show in the states
since March.
I started in Southeast Asia and
Australia and Canada and the UK and I
go,
I know a lot of these tags are going to
fucking work if I ever get back to the
states.
Yeah.
Like this is,
this is not getting what it should get.
But it's also.
And there was other bits.
Last night was my first show in the
states where like,
I'm really excited to see it.
Usually it's the opposite where I go,
I don't know if any of this is gonna
work in fucking Europe.
Right?
Right now it's like,
I can't wait to see what works.
Like what people will get offended at
that they never,
they don't give a fuck in Australia is
this,
it's never too brutal there.
But that you have with the a seismic
shift in the political and social
landscape now.
It really has been seismic,
right?
Yeah.
But I,
my audience is pretty much immune to
that.
Yeah.
Hey,
you can't talk about this anymore.
I can.
My reinforces your audience.
It reinforces your relationship with the
audience because they know,
oh,
we'll doug will give us the real deal.
He'll give us real comedy.
You know,
people are scared to do real comedy.
Right now.
Real comedy is.
Requires occasionally requires a fence.
I don't.
I don't have a sponsor or a network that
can sanction me.
They will fire you for anything.
Now.
It's the weirdest time ever.
Her getting fired.
People getting fired for things that
don't make any sense.
I'm not popular enough to get protested
or people try to lean on the venue.
Yeah.
I think it will be good for me.
Well,
Jamie was you that said the Kanye West,
the people calling the area at the time.
We live in cancel culture at this.
Cancel.
This is canceled culture that everybody
is just looking at cats.
Cancel.
Roseanne Barr to that batch I was
talking to you about.
At the same time,
I have to like watch how I phrase things
because I don't want that fucking
element.
I'm talking in hyperbole.
Yeah.
They're not Nazis,
but a lot of people that are fuckheads I
don't want that group.
I am not like anti me to by any means,
although I do make jokes about it and I
have raped material and I have,
but I got you.
It's almost like the fucking meat to
movement has pushed to fucking Maggot
people into my court and like,
Hey,
don't fucking move them over here.
That's funny.
Yeah,
it's a.
it's a funny time.
It's a time of great communication for
good or for bad and probably for both,
but there's more communication going on
right now.
Then pretty much ever anytime that I
could ever remember
furrowing my brow at what you mean by
communication because I think as a lot
of misinformation,
not saying like spectacular lines of
thinking that lead to transformative
dialogues.
Right,
but is it just Yapping pee?
More and more people are yapping and
comments there.
Yapping on twitter that yapping on
facebook and instagram is more yapping.
It's more blogs and yapping and video
yapping.
There's more communication as a lot of
opinions.
Twitter feed where you go,
hey,
you used to write jokes on here and now.
No,
I already put a whole thing about all
these comedians like saying things that
aren't even remotely funny about issues
and how how uninformed are a lot of
those opinions,
like if you questioned a lot of these
comics,
like three levels below the surface,
how much do you really know about this
issue that you're speaking about?
Because I remember when I was vaguely,
not even political,
but I was really like into the
libertarian thing and if you question
and I was open about it,
listen,
everything I know on that subject is the
bit that I did you question.
That's just surface knowledge enough to
make it funny and then I move on.
I'm not home studying this shit
afterwards like I know enough to make a
salient point which I.
I can stand behind,
but if,
if you had me on a panel talking about
it now all all I know is the bit.
That was the extent of my knowledge with
a fist fuck joke at the end.
Yeah.
Against.
Too much shit to.
No,
there's no way you could know most of
the issues that are pressing today.
There's no way.
If you have an actual job,
but an actual life and friends and shit
you like to do,
there's no way.
So we've got a bunch of people that are
arguing about shit that they're not even
barely informed.
My brain is beaten to a pulp where I,
again,
I,
I read a book two days later,
I remember if I liked it or not,
and I might remember one fact from that
that I can turn into a bit.
Right.
And then,
yeah.
What do you think your brain is
occupying?
Like W,
W,
how do you think it's an operating?
Do you think your brain is operating at
50 percent of what it was when you were
21,
75 percent?
I care about a lot less.
Right.
So I.
So how much of it is that?
Well,
I made a lot of it is fucking alcohol
under age.
Yeah.
I,
I blame the alcohol probably as much as
I should,
but I know people that are my age that I
can't remember a fucking thing and they
don't drink
well.
I think too many things happen to people
in their lives too.
I think it's impossible to remember
everything,
you know,
they have that thing where you can only
keep a certain amount of people in your
brain told Dunbar's number,
certain amount of people in your tribe,
like 150 people and keep intimate
relationships with 150 people in your
brain.
I bet that's the case with life
experiences too.
I bet that's the case with information.
I bet that's the case.
I think you only have a certain amount
of database space in your brain and I
think some people really exercise it and
expand the capacity and get it pretty
impressive,
but there's still only room for a
certain amount of shit.
There's just.
If you're really paying attention to
some things,
the other things you kind of kind of
half ass.
It was just the way of being a person
we're not designed for,
you know,
a perfect output in every single
category of things that we do.
We're designed to pay a lot of attention
to some things and as long as like food
and shelter is taking care of,
kind of barely pay attention to other
things.
Yeah,
that's what we do mostly,
but today that the chatter,
the Yap and back and forth and people
wanting to be.
Right.
I mean I've watched.
I've watched battles like twitter
battles all day long sometimes just
watch these people go back and forth.
Everybody just trying to be right.
That's never happened before.
There was never this much because people
are doing this mostly probably while
they're at work,
right?
There's supposed to be doing other shit
and like,
oh yeah,
I'll show you you fucking piece of shit.
You fucking Nazi,
you know,
and they're just typing shit at each
other and going back and forth with each
other when they're not getting anything
done.
I have someone like that.
It's an old bit about nationalism,
but because of the current climate,
people tweet that clip a lot and then
because my name is in,
then they start an intellectual twitter
war,
which is the worst when people are using
big words and fucking lots of facts and
you know,
excerpts from smart fuck magazine in a,
in a twitter battle like right.
It's one thing you have,
fuck your mother and my team's better
than your team and that shit,
but when they're having these entered
intellectual discourses about whatever
fucking climate change her know
nationalism or immigration,
but they keep me in the fucking thing
because it started with a a,
a youtube clip.
So my name,
my handle is in there and they don't
take me out of the fucking thing.
So I'm involved in these long threads
between two assholes who are trying to
outsmart each other.
You're doing this on twitter.
You can't have a legitimate argument.
That's what I told Rosanne.
Don't fucking try to tweet your way out
of this.
If you're going to tweet it all,
just keep tweeting and crazy shit til it
puts the tweet and question into this
fog of war.
If I was like a fucking cleaner.
Yeah.
That's the way that I would have flown
to her house.
If I was Ray Donovan,
I would have flown her fucking house and
I would say,
keep.
Here's more ambien.
Here's more fucking malt liquor.
Just keep doing crazy shit until it's
completely snowed over.
So that's the least of your problems.
That's so true.
I think most of the people that are
tweeting all day are either don't have a
job and they're just addicted to twitter
or they're at work and they're just
fucking off and it's supposed to be
working and so this is way more engaging
to them because they're already stuck in
this office.
So they're making sport out of like
going after people are getting at people
or communicating with people.
They're making sport out of it.
It,
it's,
it's flexing their intellectual muscles
because they're trying to find a good
argument to your point that makes you
look fucking stupid.
Doing it in 280 words is fucking.
I asked.
I mean,
we've all done it.
Oh yeah.
I love,
I love twitter trolling,
but when it's stupid,
just like fucking with people.
While you were trolling way back in the
day when you were trolling in,
but you were trolling child molesters.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The AOL Instant Messenger.
Those days.
Yeah.
That's the book.
I made a best of the book because
honestly that was the funniest shit I've
ever written.
What year was,
this?
Was the late nineties when I did the
aristocrats and they go,
you just make up the joke however you
want it.
I just took like I took verbatim stuff.
I did baiting pedophiles,
Shit.
I'm doing fucking with them.
That's.
I almost forgot about you're baiting.
It was like you had a website,
right?
It wasn't the way.
I had a website,
a website,
and they and they had stopped doing it
because they got bored with it.
So it was.
Was painting the fence where it,
Oh hey,
we'll get you to.
I asked them,
Hey,
can I do this and submit them to your
site?
I don't know how we had that much
fucking time.
I would spend 14 hour days just trying
to get a fucking full because he'd get
one that went halfway through and the
guy fails out because he figures out
your fuck with them and it's not
printable and like,
how did I have that much time?
I remember spending 12 hours on like
free poker sites playing poker and then
trolling the people because you have a,
you know,
you can chat while you play poker and
then fucking with people and just being
an asshole.
And how did I have 14 fucking because
you didn't have a job.
I still don't have a job and I still
have probably that much free time,
but now that I'm successful so I feel
like I have to keep doing something
productive.
Well,
you're also wiser.
You realize like how much time you
actually invented a invested into that
versus what you got out of it,
you know,
I mean,
how many different pedophiles did you
try to contact for?
One of them started talking to me.
Well,
you have to wait for them to contact you
roast the point because you have your
profile set up.
I'm a 13 year old girl,
likes hot,
uh,
talk with older men.
Oh,
you wrote that?
However you set it up.
I mean,
it's written cleverly so you're not
getting another fucking 13 year old kids
talking to you.
And,
uh,
but,
just the amount of time to fucking off
and having fun with it.
There was a funny story that I heard
about a dea undercovered,
dea agent who,
uh,
moved in to try to arrest another
undercovered dea agent and they playing
each other back and forth against each
other and they didn't know that both of
them were cops the entire time.
You fucking assholes.
Just wasted money.
Just wasted money investigating each
other.
So fucking stupid.
Both sides undercover.
Like,
what the fuck,
man,
if,
if trump started talking about that,
if you really wanted to keep people
around,
if you really wanted to get people on
the side,
I think what he would do is start making
drugs legal and started saying,
listen folks,
there's a reason why it's a problem in
Mexico.
And when you talk to real economists
really were talking about that on stage
last night.
Yeah,
yeah.
The real problem is the drug war make
drugs legal.
I wish I was thinking about that.
But uh,
well,
first methods Alpha fucking.
It's just such a fucking horrible drug.
Ruthless.
They make a lot of that in Mexico as
well.
Yeah,
it's a ruthless drug.
It's a ruthless drug,
but I think part of the reason why it's
so fucked up is because all of it is
illegal.
I mean,
that's a big part of why it's so fucked
up is because it's not regulated.
It's not measured.
It's the doses or not.
It doesn't say on the box what will kill
you.
You know?
You can go and bought this old camp
whiskey at any corner store.
Right?
You just go in there and buy it.
Drake,
that whole thing,
drink that whole thing.
If you weigh 100 pounds,
you're dead.
You're dead.
We all know is thinking about that.
If I did run for mayor,
I have a.
a,
a like they have the gun exchange
programs.
You have a method change.
Is it Meth for mushrooms?
Ooh,
that's a great exchange.
Give them good drugs.
They're there.
They're doing this because it's cheap
and available.
We'll get get them on good drugs.
That's.
That's actually a really good way to
approach the subject.
It wasn't one of the things that hunter
s Thompson said,
what he's running for sheriff a Pitkin
County.
He said,
uh,
any drug worth taking,
she'll never be sold and we'll,
uh,
put a stocks in the middle of the seat
in the middle of the city to lock up
dishonest drug dealers.
Drug should be free.
We're going to arrest drug dealers.
I think if we made everything legal,
we'd have real problems for sure for
quite a long period of time.
The question is whether or not you have
enough resources to parent your kids to
keep those problems from happening to
your family,
whether or not you have enough self
control to keep yourself from being one
of those problems and drugs become legal
and accessible,
but then once it settled down from there
forward,
we'd be moving in a way,
healthier place and you essentially take
all of the money out of the cartel.
They're not making any money anymore and
then they're not going to be this
murderers gang of us.
It's gonna take a while for things to
dissipate,
but look what they did to Columbia.
I mean,
Columbia used to be fucking crazy and
now you can go there and it's supposed
to be really nice.
You go to Bogota.
It's supposed to be a really nice place.
It's,
it's safe.
I want to go to South America and I
can't.
I mean,
South America,
it's the only continent I haven't been
to.
Antarctica doesn't count.
But uh,
if there's nothing,
I've never found a place that looks like
I want to go with Argentina looks bad
ass.
Really?
Yeah.
That's a Argentina's near the glacier.
It's fucking beautiful down there.
Yeah.
No roads talks highly about it,
but he's Argentinian.
Busy.
His,
some of his.
He's got family down there and yeah,
look,
there's some fucking beautiful spots,
beautiful spots in this country and this
world.
But uh,
South America,
South America.
The weirdest thing is like how much
jungle it is.
Like you look at how much of like
Bolivia and Brazil,
how much of it is actual jungle,
you know,
like Holy Shit,
like,
no wonder why these people don't.
Most every one of them has some kind of
fucking rebel army shit going on and
kidnapping.
It was nothing that seemed safe like
Costa Rica,
you know,
you're probably not going to have a lot
of issues.
Right,
right,
right.
But everything I've looked up,
I was on the beach in Costa Rica with my
kid and some dude offered me coke.
I was walking,
holding hands with a five year old dude
was offered me coke.
My guy had not right now.
Not right now.
It's just like that.
Just get you whatever you want.
Gringo,
you know,
he come down here to party,
I know you don't live here,
motherfucker.
Who come here for a good time?
Where'd you go?
Um,
I don't remember,
man.
It was a couple of years ago.
But uh,
we,
we drove to a couple of different places
in Costa Rica.
Where did you fly into San Jose or
Liberia?
Liberia.
Right.
And then we went to the rain forest.
Did the ziplining did I heard a horrible
thing?
I think it was just the honeymoon.
Couple of Tan.
Yeah.
They crashed into each other and killed
the guy and put the girl in a coma.
They crashed into each other on a zip
line.
Yeah.
So the one of them get stuck.
Yeah,
and the other guys coming down,
it's like it's like a fat kid into
fucking a water slide gets stuck in the
tube,
but then the next one comes down and
smashes and they were going so fast to
men.
You're going so fast,
you're on the zip line.
You're flying.
I did.
I did that once just to say I did
something the first time I went to Costa
Rica.
Yeah,
that's enough.
After that,
I'm happy.
Fat on a Boogie Board.
Yeah.
I did it once too and I kept thinking,
when do they check this wire?
This wire as a mile long,
how are they checking?
This wire is not as strong.
Work Ethic and Costa Rica either know
those dudes who worked there who were
just climbing up and hitch and people
onto those things like they're a little
too comfortable with the edge.
Those people are just a little too
comfortable with hanging off the trees
clip and ropes on the wires and shooting
it down a little too casual.
Little too casual about that endeavor.
Yeah.
One of the scariest things I've ever
done is the cab ride from Hako to San
Jose in the capital and they're fucking
speeding around what should be like 15
mile an hour curves and there's a,
you know,
an ox and a cart in the fucking middle
of the road and you just had a
collegiate coming down.
So one of the things that I used to
always be fascinated by bourdain's show
was his willingness to continue to go to
these places where you had to take these
trucks down,
these dirt roads and you look out the
window and you see a sheer cliff and up
ahead.
There's a fucking landslide.
Now they get to bring in a tractor to
move the rocks away for landslide.
Like,
Oh Dude,
David Vietnam where you're,
you're,
you're in the cab from the airport and
there's just see like a Sturgis of
Vietnamese people.
They're all on this,
this sea of motorcycles and scooters.
And like,
you're literally moving in your seat,
like they're going to hit it and somehow
it works.
Like Cirque de Solei that crash,
but they don't crash it.
Those birds in the sky moved together.
Yeah.
That's how they figured that out.
How to all of them to get together.
Look at all these people.
Yeah.
This is insanity.
That is just straight and Saturday.
Three lights or anything.
There's nothing there.
Cars are just driving through.
Have you ever been in Mexico City?
Might even be.
That might be the view from where I was
staying.
I was staying in the hotel where they
have the iconic picture of the,
uh,
the last helicopter,
CIA,
helicopter landing,
taking off from the roof of the hotel
and people are like climbing to be the
last person on there.
That was the hotel we were at that.
Whoa.
Where that helicopter was landing is now
a rooftop bar.
Wow.
And that was the hotel we did the Gig in
Vietnam.
Supposed to be awesome.
No.
If you're adventurous,
if you're Tom Rhodes,
I'm sure it's fantastic if you're,
where you're terrified to go out of the
hotel.
No,
no,
not at all.
That rooftop bars.
Great for Dane.
Loved it.
It was like one of his favorite places
to go eat.
He loved Vo.
That's where he,
uh,
he had,
eight with the president.
Yeah.
Obama.
That's right.
They may still call it the
president,
the president.
He's my president.
He was my president.
Did you see when the NBC wrote out about
Oprah,
here's to our president,
it was an amazing speech by our
president.
They put an NBC,
put it on their twitter page and then
someone came along and went,
what the fuck are you doing?
I love when people say,
well,
what do you.
When you complain about something and
they go,
yeah,
well,
Obama did the same thing and no one
shedding.
I wasn't.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't know.
And uh,
that's not the point still sucks you
when you make a point about an issue
that it's a left or right thing while
you were actually defending a person or
a like,
no,
this is fucked up and wrong.
Will Obama did it?
Well,
there's still fucked up and wrong.
I never,
I like,
I think Obama's a really fucking cool
guy as a personality,
but I'm sure every print.
Yeah,
Bill Clinton did horrible fucking things
and Yo,
uh,
like increased sentencing from fucking
drug stuff and what?
Yeah,
but he was a good personality and I
don't give a fuck.
I don't imagine
a guy or girl that's supposed to be
paying attention to every single issue
that's going on in this country and
making decisions about all of it and
doing it all,
investigating every single issue
perfectly.
Getting all the right advice from all
the advisors carefully considering each
and every step the fuck out of here.
There's no way they can.
There's no way the president really
knows what's going on with all the
different problems in this country.
There's no fucking way
possible if,
if we just became a,
a cool country like Norway and just
close all the bases around the world.
Don't be world police.
We're just gonna be a fun country like
fucking Iceland.
I just bring all the troops back and no
more.
Go ahead with the were disarming you
guys.
I think shit would calm down.
I think the world would calm down
as long as we kept our guns,
as long as they keep our weapons and
keep the same amount of people in the
military,
bring them back home,
but make them exercise here at the
problem is as soon as any one superpower
drifts away,
they leave a vacuum and another super
power try to rise up.
That's the big fear.
That's what the big military proponents
fear is that if we're not strong,
someone else will become stronger and
then we'll be weak,
will be attacked and that it does happen
other places in the world and we can't
be so naive as to think it'll never
happen again.
So give it a shot and if it doesn't work
out,
fuck it.
I don't know how you can take any
president seriously now as we're aging
and put time and perspective for years
is nothing,
so I'm going to make a deal with you.
Have four years later is going to be
another asshole goes,
Nah,
nevermind.
Scrap that.
I think there's a ticket.
Dictators not a bad thing,
as long as he's a good one.
Yeah,
you've done evolent dictator.
That's like a monk dictate.
We all have a good time.
Fucking 15 hour work week.
Well,
here's the
question in the United States was
founded because people have decided they
didn't like the way things are running
in Europe.
They didn't like monarchies.
They didn't like being under the rule of
the king or queen.
They wanted to do it by elected
officials that wanted to have a
representative democracy or a
representative,
democratic republic.
They wanted to figure out something new.
So they came over here and did it.
What would be the resistance?
What if say like everybody tried to do
what they did up in Oregon and start a
new country somewhere and people like,
fuck this.
We're going to go to this spot.
Look,
global warming is clearing off some nice
swatches,
a land in Antarctica.
We're just gonna move up there.
It's fucking beautiful and green.
Just fuck it.
We're done.
And then over there we're going to
barely have an army.
And uh,
you know,
just have a bunch of dudes.
Look on the lookout with guns,
make sure we don't get robbed.
And that's it.
And you know,
healthcare.
Yeah,
we'll pay for that education today.
we'll pay for education.
Yeah,
do whatever you want to do
pile then fucking kids and ruin it.
Damn,
that's the problem.
Right?
Overpopulation,
but how long would it take to
overpopulate greenland?
Well,
that's what they were trying to do.
Yeah,
I looked into greenland is a weird place
to go visit.
Iceland is fantastic.
It's just the little dull.
That's the problem with all these.
The best place to live is Norway and
Scandinavia and Iceland,
but there is a.
it's Kinda there.
Everyone's nice.
It's like going up fucking northern
Minnesota and everyone's niceness
though.
There's no excitement.
There's no.
A buddy of mine that's just adrenaline.
Montana said he was living in Bozeman
and I said,
you didn't love Boseman.
He says like,
it's all a bunch of boring white people
that just.
They're really into bikes.
Yeah,
really into biking.
Great calves.
That's what he said.
Dance.
Boring white people.
But I mean,
that's one of the good things about what
you do is that you can be in your town
and then you can go other places,
but you always have that town versus if
you get stuck.
Like we were talking about people that
are just living in Columbus,
Ohio,
their whole life.
Not to pick on Columbus,
but near St Louis,
whatever name is city versus someone who
travels around all over the place.
The same can be said about someone who
lives in La.
If you grow up here and you think this
is the world of this,
this crazy congested slab of human rose
piled on top of each other.
Now the rest of the world is.
There's some spots where you can go to
where there's hardly anybody.
You ever been to Idaho?
Boise,
Idaho.
Did you?
Yeah.
I lived in a town of 400 people for
Awhile when I was 22.
No Shit.
Yeah,
a little cabin on the south fork of the
payette river,
about 55 miles north of Boise.
There's some lakes up there where you
go,
I shouldn't even be allowed to be here.
Like,
this is too pretty,
like this seems like you should have to
pay to be here or this should be
restricted access or something.
Like it's fucking gorgeous up there.
I,
I was,
I was 22 and I,
my wife left me,
I moved to Boise just because it sounded
funny.
Fraud,
telemarketing.
So I could do it anywhere.
There's a phone,
right?
I'm in business.
And then uh,
after we moved to Boise and immediately
my wife left me for my best friend.
We all moved out there together and then
my other buddy that moved with us
couldn't handle the stress so he went
back to Vegas.
So I'm all my shit to boise and within
two weeks I'm alone.
So I moved up to this fucking.
I bought a cabin,
like a for sale by owner.
Like,
like I didn't get a loan.
I was like,
Hey,
I'm just going to give you was,
what do you call it?
We're just signed a contract and I'll
pay you.
I didn't go through a bank owner,
financed owner finance and a little
cabin and the two bars in town.
And you were either a long branch guy or
you're the dirty shame guy and I was a
dirty shame saloon guy and I would drive
back and forth because in a small town
they open around noon but
not necessarily at Niu.
And how old were you then?
Twenty two.
That's hilarious.
No fucking chicks there.
So you would drive back and forth in
front of the bar until Jolie showed up
to open.
So it's 1215.
I've been just driving back and forth,
waiting for it to open and I would have.
I lasted like six months and then I had
to ditch out on the front.
You there by yourself?
Owner financing?
Yeah,
at one point my buddy that moved back to
vegas came up and he was there for a
couple months,
but we'd get on the phone just enough to
pay our bar tab.
In fact,
my bar tab,
I traded out like furniture when I.
When I bailed six months later I traded
jolene like my furniture in the cabin
for my bar tab.
And yeah,
it was fucking crazy.
So you could set your own hours when
you're doing that.
Scam.
Telemarketing stuff,
he just did it whenever you wanted to
and they just got you clocked in.
You got paid out of my cabin was just
pick up the phone.
I had leads I stole from Vegas.
And,
and what did you do?
Like how did that work?
I'd call up businesses and then add the
pitch and you won one of these awards
and you just have to buy this many pens
like ad copy and ad specs,
advertising specialties.
This mug with A.
Hey Joe,
uh,
you won a big award and I'm going to.
All you have to do is make a small
purchase of these mugs with your
business name on them,
the Joe Rogan podcast,
and you're guaranteed to win this big
award.
That's worth way.
Wow.
So it was just a total scam.
Yeah.
Wow.
But cleverly phrased,
so to stay in that gray area of legal
were like,
whoa.
I knew a dude who has
really interesting scam.
He had a scam where they were making a.
It was a company that would allow you to
fix your credit.
So they would give you a line of credit
and a,
you would buy things and then pay off
the credit and it would boost your
credit backs if you had fucked up
credit.
It was,
it was allowing you to fix your credit.
But the catch was the only things that
you could buy with their credit card was
things from their catalog.
So
a soul to the company's story.
I,
you know,
those things.
So they had these catalogs scam
stuff,
but say if something costs,
uh,
you know,
whatever it was,
a toenail clipper for costs like $3 at
the grocery store there is $25.
So if you want to buy it,
you're,
you're giving them a giant chunk of
profit.
So they would ship these terrible little
items and it would really actually boost
these people's credit.
It actually did work were.
So it was enough that it was a total
scam.
So you're the only shit they can buy
with your credit cards and stuff from
your catalog and everything's marked up
through the fucking roof.
And this made millions
on that.
Made millions.
What aspects of the products,
like what I was working for a company
originally we would have the uh,
the uh,
a black mat,
a pen with the gold medal Florentine
Trim and five lines of your ad copy on
it and we'd be selling these fucking
twenty five cent pens for like $4 a
piece.
So it was put the scan that I was just
getting into when I started doing comedy
and then bailed out and went full time.
And comedy was the uh,
the invention once,
like the George Foreman.
Oh look the grill.
Yeah.
Do you have an invention?
And it's a fucking.
It's just such a great scam because egos
involved and it's good.
You know,
everyone thinks they should be on shark
tank.
Those kind of people.
And you go,
I can't say,
but I think what you have here and that.
And then it's a multilevel where vent
help.
There it is.
Submit your invention idea to companies.
I'm not saying invent help is a scam.
I'm saying scams of that.
Do you have an invention?
And then there's a step one is we're
going to do a,
like a,
a patent,
a research to see,
and this is going to cost you this,
but honestly Phil,
I think you're onto something.
I can't say that this is a million
dollar idea,
but I know when I have a feeling the way
you say it and you could see like it
would be so easy and I was just starting
to do that.
Did you feel awful when you get off the
phone?
No,
not.
I didn't feel awful till years later.
While I never did get into that fully
where I was just starting to do that out
of my house,
out of my apartment in Vegas when I
like,
I'm going full time and comedy.
So I.
But the other scams,
no,
I never felt bad because you were.
They say,
oh they're ripping off old people.
No,
we were ripping off young greedy fucking
people that think they're going to
fucking get something for nothing.
And a business.
Small business thing work.
Like what if someone did have a good
invention?
I don't know.
I never got that far into it.
I was just starting where I go,
fuck this.
I don't have time.
I'm doing comedy.
I got to.
I got an offer.
I moved to Phoenix and I got a job as a
house Mc six,
six months?
Yeah,
about six months after I started I fell
in love with a girl and Phoenix moved
down there,
got a job as a house mc in a where I all
I was getting.
I was getting a free hotel room.
The club was in a a days inn I think it
was,
so I'll get a free hotel so I had a
place to live and I could do comedy five
nights a week and talk to the Gig chef
loved me and would give me free food.
You do shows in Bisbee now?
I,
I have other people come to Bisbee.
I filmed my last.
It's a throwaway special,
but I just did it like as an experiment
in the fun house.
So basically this room but not maybe not
quite this big.
It's an 18 by 20 box with a bar built
and a little tiny stage in the corner
and I've filmed.
It's a pop off vodka presents and
evening would tug stan hope and now
we're selling it on vhs.
I don't know if we're sold out,
but we the only physical copies of vhs.
Really?
Yeah.
You can get it on Vimeo.
It's digital,
but I,
I took about an hour's worth of material
that uh,
I think there's only 20 minutes on the
vhs,
just the bit about pop up vodka presents
where we tried to get sponsorship with
pop off because it's fucking low grade
shitty vodka and I thought that would be
a funny sponsor and Brian reached out
and through channels that they said the
pop off wouldn't touch doug stanhope
with a 10 foot pole as what they said.
So I have this giant 20 minute fucking
bit about it and I like I'm going to be
sponsored by popoff vodka against their
will and I'm going to fucking make a
special call Papa Vodka presents and I'm
going to keep doing it until they give
me a cease and desist the.
But I took an hour of material that get
cut out of other specials where I go.
I really liked that bit.
I just had to cut it down to an hour.
I'm going to put this out as the papa
vodka presents.
That's hilarious.
Do they know,
haven't gotten the cease and desist
shirts?
It flopped up.
Fuck you.
Special.
You're going to tell me you're fucking
rot.
Gut fucking.
They wouldn't touch liquid.
Jake was almost always the best word to
use I think in a bit.
I think I'd say Hobo Plasma.
Oh,
bit that I uh,
but I want to experiment more with that.
And we've had a bunch of comics.
Olivia grace who opened last night.
She came down to Bisbee for road comics
going to La.
You know what?
I'm going to do gigs in Austin.
It's kind of on the way.
So we've had a bunch of comics down and
get drunk and go,
hey,
let's fucking do a show because if 15
people in that room,
it's tiny enough that that's a real
audience and we've never had a bad show.
They're like,
it just it.
And so yeah.
I want to film stuff.
I want to start experimenting with doing
like just putting out singles,
like my bits are fucking like you have
bits that are fucking 17 minutes.
I don't,
I'm not like Hedberg.
I don't want to have one liners so I can
take a 16 minute bit and just
sell that as a single volume ninety nine
cents on itunes or I don't know how the.
I don't know how that side of.
It's not a bad idea.
It probably,
you know,
there's a lot of people that do their
podcasts with a subscription.
Like Nick Depaulo just released his new
podcast and he's doing a subscription
service.
We have to pay to listen to it can get.
That's one of the things when I retire
is figure out shit like Patrion I've
heard about and you can do this and
yeah,
you just get people to give you money.
Yeah.
That's nice.
Let just give you must give me money.
They just give you money.
Like I really support you on Patrion.
Like there's a lot of people that do
that.
They just do stuff like please support
my Patrion oh,
please give me money.
Yeah,
I don't really like working.
I like just talking in front of this
Youtube Camera,
so if you like me talking to please
support my patrion w when everyone talks
about their new hour,
I'm doing usually an hour and a half now
and I'm not doing five different bits
that I really liked that I just got
bored with,
but I still haven't recorded so I could
put out a chunk of those like leftovers
and no one's buying a fucking DVD
anymore.
They're getting everything digital.
That's true.
So why not just,
hey,
this is a great 20 minutes.
I'm tired of it.
Let's put it out.
Yeah,
it's not a bad idea.
I mean you could do youtube red to or
you do it through subscriptions.
There's a bunch of different ways to do
it now.
It's a,
there's more options every day.
Two,
it's,
it's becoming interesting.
I don't know.
Amazon releases a lot of stuff now too.
They're releasing a lot of standup.
It's a.
it's really kind of amazed since there's
only one youtube.
That's what's really amazing.
I mean,
Vimeo does exist and it is good,
but in terms of like when people think
of like one platform where you get
videos on,
he really only think of Youtube.
Yeah.
Uh,
and monetizing.
I don't know how any of that works and
Jamie could tell you I can help you.
It's not that complicated.
Yeah.
A lot of people do it and we're going to
have to fucking start doing video for
our podcast.
Yeah.
How come you don't like doing that?
I just hate being on camera.
Like here you have it subtle enough.
I remember that your old studio where
I'm looking at my face on a.
We start remembering the tripping that
bad bad day.
Yeah.
We shouldn't have done that way.
That way was dumb because when we
realized somewhere along the line that
when they were up on that screen,
like we would look at ourselves on that
screen.
It would make you think about it.
And then somewhere along the line I
said,
let's stop doing this.
It's just doesn't seem like it's just a
couple of Gopros.
Yeah.
It's weird.
So it's an added unnecessary element
you're thinking about.
I don't think about that camera or that
camera.
No.
Yeah,
yeah.
But I remember the first time I did your
podcast and we were sitting on a couch.
We're side by side,
so it's awkward and it was uncomfortable
couches or uncomfortable to like sit and
talk.
Like sit up and talk like you're sinking
into him and it just starts bothering
you.
You want to look across someone you
went,
yeah.
This is going to be nine years in
December.
Yeah.
Look at you
crazy.
Yeah.
That couch was in [inaudible] house for.
You still have to make me hard sign.
Yeah.
That was offensive to offensive for
comedy central are you're doing.
So you're fun.
House is like,
you have an extra house so you have like
your main house where you live in and
then you have the fun house that has a
bar and we have a guest house and you
bought a couple houses in town too,
right?
Yeah.
We get a few.
You're going to be,
you're becoming your own,
uh,
Oregon cult.
Like just slowly buy up the town.
Start renting it out to people that you
like.
That's what the free state project
remember that the Libertarian Movement
to try to get everyone to move to one
state and that way we can all vote
because we get one percent of the vote
nationally,
but if we all lived in one state than we
could.
Yeah.
Then they picked New Hampshire.
Hi.
I'm not going to fucking fuck you.
It's just too hard to get laid up there.
It's too fucking cold.
It's too cold.
I haven't seen winter and many years.
I remember a Fitzsimmons got kicked out
of a Gig up there and they had told him
not to drive at night because there's so
many moose on the road.
But uh,
they kicked them out of the Gig for
swearing.
They filed.
They fired him when he,
when he got there,
they had his bags packed when he got off
stage and they said,
you're fired.
Get out because you're supposed to be
there for the weekend.
And they made them drive home.
I'm guessing this is a long time ago.
Oh yeah.
We were both starting out.
Fucking Fitzsimmons is a hothead.
Oh,
he's a hothead.
Is that.
I never saw that in him.
Oh yeah.
He's always been.
He's Irish.
He's always been a hothead as long as
I've done a podcast a few years ago and
he almost came to fisticuffs with a
fucking parking attended.
Like,
fuck you.
You want to fucking like,
really?
Yeah.
His face just fucking beet red.
He was gonna beat the fuck out of the
guy just ignored me.
He was so angry.
I was just waiting there to do his
podcast and he just blows by me like I'm
a problem to like fuck,
just ate raged.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And then we get on the podcast and he's
fine.
Professional.
Yeah,
I do too.
We started out together like within a
week apart from each other.
Oh no shit.
Yeah,
we're buddies.
We're raw open micros.
We steal jokes from each other,
like we didn't really have enough
material to do like a half an hour.
So like he would do some
of my shit.
I do some of his shit and he would tell
me,
Oh yeah,
that blow job.
It worked great and fucking some shit
hole in the middle of nowhere.
Like when you,
when we were like a year and we were
both about a year and when we started
getting paid gigs,
but when you're a year and you've really
don't have shit.
My first,
my first right before I moved to
Phoenix,
my first paid road Gig was in flagstaff
for Sandy Hackett.
And I was co headlining with a
ventriloquist who'd never worked at
comedy club.
He only worked at the county fair
circuits.
And he was,
I remember he was so weird.
He was an old historic hotel that we
were staying in that they put us up in.
The gig is in and he moved to a
different hotel because this was so old.
He thought it was a fire hazard.
And he said one time he played a cruise
ship and someone threw his dummy
overboard and he can't go through that
again if he lost this dummy in a fire.
So he paid probably as much as he was
making for the Gig to get his own hotel.
It was a decent hotel.
And uh,
I,
I remember,
I think I only had to do like 30 or 35
minutes and I was stretching to get 27
with everything I had.
I remember stealing some jokes from one
of the Vegas open mic or is where I
lived at.
Go back and say,
Oh hey,
I use some of your material because I
had to fill time and then find I find
out later that was.
And they look at you sideways.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
All right.
It was,
I really don't do it again.
Okay.
Yeah,
those,
uh,
road gigs back then that mean you didn't
realize it at the time,
but what a,
it's all of it builds up to be this
giant education in how to do standup and
those,
the foundation of those road gigs is
irreplaceable.
Yeah.
All my favorite comics,
they started out doing the road,
you know,
all,
everybody.
Joey,
you,
Ari Duncan.
I don't know
if anyone has done this as a gimmick.
I know that this is a town of Gimmick
shows.
My first notebook as anything.
Yeah.
Owen,
Benjamin.
I mean,
not all.
Benjamin Owen Smith,
Owen Smith has a show that he does
online where I brought him some
notebooks from like 90 to 91 and 92
terrible material,
terrible.
And we read,
we read over some of the jokes and I
even had like forced setups and forced
like audience interaction.
I fake audience interaction where asked
him a question and pretend to hear an
answer.
Oh,
it was awful.
It was awful.
I'm like,
am I right ladies?
Like I had that.
Is this on stage?
We did it in the back bar of the comedy
store and we would go over the.
We were going over the notebook just
laughing.
Oh I bet I have,
but I a fun show
is you have to go up and do your fucking
do the act.
Right,
right.
Well the thing is I don't,
I didn't have the act like clearly
written.
Now all you have material from the first
notebook.
Well back then if I wrote a hundred
things down and one of them was halfway
worth talking about it,
it was amazing because I didn't know
what I was doing.
I first notebook.
I have written out my four minutes or
whatever it was including.
Hi,
my name is Doug Stanhope is written
well,
if you want to practice correctly.
I know guys who used to practice in
front of the mirror.
They would just stand in front of the
mirror and do their act.
Hey,
am I right or a monitor wrong?
We do here.
I don't know if I ever did that,
but I was certainly the guy pacing in
the back alley saying it out loud and
know with the hand gestures and
everything.
Yeah,
just going over in your head.
I know a guy used to do.
Yeah.
I know I used to do is act on camera.
He do it alone in a room like in a
bedroom,
set up camera and do his act to the
camera and then go back and watch and
analyze it.
Oh,
I got you.
You get those emails.
Hey,
I'm doing comedy now.
Tell me what you think and you click on
the link and it's a youtube of them in
their basement.
Just Thompson camera by themselves.
Like the with the eyes of that youtube
shooter lady.
Creepy reading you off their material.
Imagine having to do it again.
It's one of the things that Dan Cook
said once.
The one thing that I could never imagine
doing in life is starting over as a
standup from the beginning again,
like
as I have an idea,
but I'm not,
I don't want to.
I don't want to air it,
but something that I want to do in my,
in my retirement years.
But uh,
it's not quite that but.
But what comics ask you,
like the amount of emails,
what advice do you have?
How do I start out?
Well,
I don't know.
I haven't started in 28 years,
so I want to interact with you.
They're just trying to find a way to
interact with you.
If they wanted us to figure out how to
start out.
This is not,
they're not going to be able to ask you.
They got to go to open mic nights.
Ask the guide.
That's if you haven't done an open mic
at,
go to an open mic and ask an open mic or
where do I do?
And if you're an open mic or that wants
to get work as an mc than asking him see
what he did,
he asked the guy just above you because
he knows.
I don't know how the fuck you think I
know what the Dorfman's look for in a
fuck.
But uh,
yeah,
I mean,
if you want to be a theory,
theoretical mathematician,
you don't go to.
Some guy was teaching at Harvard and
say,
Hey man,
how do I get started?
I haven't gone to elementary school yet,
but I'm thinking about it.
It means people that want advice,
like there's no way you can give an
advice anyway.
You would have to see them a whole bunch
of times.
And even then you'd have to be like,
hmm,
what are you trying to do?
Were you trying to go and then watch
them or watch them try to get better.
I mean,
the best advice you could ever give us.
Do it.
Listen,
record.
Write down what sucks about it.
Write down what work.
Well do it again,
right?
Right.
Performed,
suck,
right?
Repeat.
And you're going to start as a five word
response performed suck.
Rewrite,
repeat,
just keep doing it.
You have to keep doing it.
It's something that you just don't.
You're not going to be great right off.
Like anybody that thinks they're going
to be amazing at this.
Like right off the bat you're like,
oh,
I can't.
It's not possible,
and if you're asking me,
I might think you suck.
Yeah.
And if I say,
well,
you suck.
Well other people might think you're
funny,
so don't listen to me.
That was the best.
My refrain.
Joey Zola was a guy that was just a
little above me and I was given advice
to a kid that was just below me when I
was at know,
just above open miker and Jelly pulled
me aside.
He goes,
don't give these kids advice because all
you ever doing is telling them how to be
like,
you know.
Yeah,
that's true.
That is,
I would have fucking told Dane Cook.
Yeah,
you're never going to.
You're never going to be good at this.
I'm not your audience.
Well,
comedy is always going to suffer from
that because there's no categories,
you know?
I mean,
it's not like a blues or.
Yeah.
Disco,
you know,
Jazz,
rock and roll,
there's comedy and there's different
kinds of comedy,
different ways doing,
but there's no categories.
So they used to build me as x rated just
because there wasn't a category,
but they wanted to warn people.
The signs that I still have on all my
shows to this day,
it said,
it says warning Joe Rogan show contains
the strongest material content
imaginable because.
Because like I got tired of people
complaining,
I said,
tell them that it contains like the most
fucked up things imaginable.
So if they read that and they go in,
I couldn't be like,
wow,
I couldn't imagine that.
Like it says,
the most mature thing imaginable.
I was,
I remember a plane xannies in Chicago
and having a really hard week of
walkouts and angry people even though
they build it as,
you know,
adult or x rated.
Yeah.
There's my.
I post that all my shows.
I've had that shit.
That's what you were just in Tucson.
It didn't go Tucson's fucking great.
First of all,
how cool does it desert look out there?
It looks fake and all those.
The guy was us,
told us that there were a cactuses that
have gps in them because people are
stealing cactuses,
so it's still cactus,
the GPS and the cactus and arrest
people,
their house,
the fucking cactus Solara desert.
Did you drive back after that kid?
Because I went to Phoenix.
We drove to feed.
And you told me you didn't come up?
Yeah,
I'm originally,
I was going to do other gigs that week,
but it's too many things.
Got moved around.
I want to flying into boise the next
day.
Um,
when you,
uh,
traveled to Asia,
how many different places do you go
where it's all x paths.
It's all ex pat.
That's the first time I've done one of
those Tom Rhodes tours where,
uh,
it was a Hong Kong,
Singapore did Shanghai a Hoochie Minh
City.
Tokyo,
Tokyo.
Tokyo is fascinating.
Huh?
It seems like a whole different world
like this.
Look at you.
You landed in an alien world where the
languages all different with the people
look like us there,
you know,
I can put a little different that didn't
really didn't venture out much.
Uh,
but yeah,
it's pretty weird.
But everyone's friendly.
Yeah.
Singapore is fucking amazing.
It's like that movie Elisa,
them.
Oh really is absolutely safe.
Beautiful.
No crime.
Super wealthy.
Right.
Very wealthy.
Like more than New York City.
Like more expensive to live in the New
York City.
I don't know.
I,
I know it's very expensive.
Uh,
I was doing a,
they were paying for all these five star
hotels and shit where I probably took a
bath on the guarantee.
If I paid my own way,
I could've done it way cheaper.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's super wealthy.
Like Hong Kong is all fucking
international banker flux.
That's high dollar and Singapore are the
people that pay them.
Oh Wow.
So,
uh,
you know,
it wasn't the ex pats I was expecting.
So when you're there,
like how big are the places you're
doing?
Uh,
I was like 600 ish.
mostly people from,
well not necessarily the state,
somewhere in England,
Australia,
Canada,
and there's just a lot of people that
moved there for work or.
Well,
Hong Kong and Singapore.
Again,
a lot of international banker,
you know,
fucking tight suits,
lots of blow,
probably skinny,
skinny jeans.
And below 10 bucks and want to see my
new car.
Come on.
Vietnam,
Bangkok,
little seedier.
How many different places do you do in
Asia?
That was in Bangkok,
Thailand,
Vietnam,
Hong Kong,
Shanghai.
I think I'm missing a couple.
Uh,
Tokyo now.
It was,
but it was a,
it was so quick.
So you're doing a different country
every day.
So every day is another fucking visa,
you know,
customs and just
crush you and your immune system.
Now the constant traveling.
When I'm traveling every day,
I can only do that a few days in a row
after awhile I'm like,
what?
Because I don't get any sleep.
I don't sleep well when I'm getting up
in the morning.
You got to get up early for the flight.
Then you try to take a nap.
You're barely sleep.
You sleep a few hours at night,
you got to get up in the morning again.
You're doing a show.
So you're wired after the show and then
they're like two,
three days in your exhaust it,
it was pretty brutal.
Yeah.
I think the way to do it is to spread it
out over long periods of time so that
you do a Gig and then you hang out in
the city for like a few days,
chill out,
see what's there,
then move onto the next place.
I I liked.
All right,
let's get it out of the way because
those days off I go,
oh wow.
Look at temple.
Let's party.
Look at the Buddha.
Let's drink.
Let's go with a Buddha.
I,
I'm a lot healthier when I have a lot of
gigs in a row because then I stay sober
until show time.
You tried quitting cigarettes for a
while?
Yeah.
How?
I always try.
How long did you have for?
The longest was a year in 2008.
Really?
I did six weeks of.
Of couple years ago and then got a book
deal and what?
Alright.
That's the one thing I can't fuck.
I cannot write and not smoke.
Really?
Yeah.
That's still the hardest thing to do.
Quitting like eventually.
Okay.
Yeah.
I can go.
I can drink and not smoke.
I can go out and I could do interviews
on the phone.
That's usually where you get to do
interviews.
I'm chain smoking,
but writing a book,
writing now it's just constant.
Hinchcliffe had a real problem with
that.
Who Hinchcliffe he would write when you
write for roasts and things like that.
Always be smoking cigarettes is
associated cigarettes with writing,
but he quit smoking cigarettes and it
took them awhile.
So there was a cranky period.
Took a while to like get over the hump.
Got One of those vape pens.
Yeah.
Bingo.
Uses those.
That's what I was going to.
I said I'm going to bring your vape pen
to Rogan's because I don't want to smoke
and ruin his fucking studio again and
fine.
Seems to be working good.
I mean,
I could smell it,
but I mean there's no,
it's not like thick in the air.
The fan works.
Does it have filters?
Jamey,
do we have to clean filters?
Do we know anything
after,
after today,
motherfucker.
Douglas.
It's already 2:00.
Uh,
we did three hours.
Really?
Yeah.
No Shit doesn't even make sense.
Right?
Time flies by that.
Um,
anything to tell these people nothing to
promote.
This is on my first day of retirement,
the retirement of Doug's Stan hope,
which we'll get to take a 10 day train
trip going nowhere but on the train.
Go to Chicago to Saunders,
Chicago to Portland,
down to La and back to Tucson.
Salsify hanging around on a train.
Beautiful.
Yeah.
I love it.
Love fucking moving.
Yeah man.
I mean you don't have to do anything.
You can do whatever the fuck you want.
That's the American dream.
The American dream is not just success.
It's also freedom.
Freedom to do whatever.
Not Be trapped.
Like to,
to be wise enough to not be trapped by
your bills or your previous commitments.
Bang it out,
make enough money,
stockpile your finances and go,
okay,
we're good.
It's just,
it's just fucking chill.
Live cheap.
Discount meets lesson to you all.
America live like Doug Stanhope or
don't.
Is that it?
That's it.
Goodnight everybody.
Thanks.
Bye.
That was fucking three hours.